a four month traffic jam um but it's yeah it's like i say
you know what's great i brought i brought milk i i brought
milk yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i know i know the traffic jam
was for i i don't know i know it's like it was in that
traffic jam for four very long months but like we're back
we're back for little nightmares three part two
yeah yeah yeah see i i feel like i swear to you i feel like
this game is cursed i feel like because it's like we're like
don't worry we're gonna come back to this game and then the
first time the first collab we res get this we scheduled for
it sorry i also just woke up like 10 minutes go at the worst
sleep of my life um but like not it's you know it's like
your dad came up came over hung over you're supposed to take
her to disneyland and you're like hung over as fuck it's
like don't worry kid we're we're yeah yeah yeah i have my i
got my special paper bag you know it's it's it's daddy's
special brown paper bag don't touch it uh it's it's it's
adult juice for adults you're not supposed to drink it
you're not only only daddy can drink this it gets really
weird
oh oh wait chibi oh yeah they couldn't hear you oh my god my
sound settings yeah i was just talking to my voice the
voices in my head sorry the one very loud voice in my head
right now uh wait wait they still can't hear you can't talk
about all this yeah you gotta make don't don't let it out
yet full address oh my god wait their ip address is 1.6 why
do you stop keep going come on why are you stop you think i
i can't play the same game too i'm hacking i'm getting if
you're gonna take me down i'll take you down with me uh
let's do an ip review that'll be yeah it's like let's who
let's see who gets docs first let's see who shows up outside
the door first yeah you can post a picture in my house
before the other one yeah he shows up all right wait okay
where was i oh my gosh i'm my brain is still waking up right
now um oh yeah okay do you want me to like do something when
we first try to schedule this part two of this collab you
got sick right or was it me okay yeah you got i think it was
me yeah you got really sick and like because you're still
sick too the well in the mind no didn't you just tweet i
literally saw it today i saw you tweet out saying that your
voice hurts i was like oh i have ibuprofen oh i got
ibuprofen so we're good right now yeah let's tanking it
we're gonna tank it and two hours i'm gonna be like I was
like, Chibi, we gotta finish this game.
It's been four months, Chibi.
Just get through this.
I can't receive another court order that I have to show up
for your birthday.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There's a chance you might come to my birthday.
Well, well, that's why we're having the collab now.
Happy birthday.
This is your present.
You're a little early.
You're a little early, then.
happy birthday oh my god you ruined the surprise you ruined
the surprise against you why can't you do anything right
please don't do please not again don't walk in my room oh i
worked so hard to give you this amazing birthday present
which is i know my appearance you know my presence you spend
time with me my birthday presence is you acknowledging my
existence exactly and you get my number and no no i didn't
block it i was just you know really busy you know every time
you called me someone you know you know daddy is a really
really a busy man you know so every time you happen to call
me i was just in another work call you know you want you
want your dad to lose her job you well i know you you have
to keep your job exactly so like how are you putting all the
milk you and get exactly you want you want me to stop buying
us milk you know you know i'm trying to i'm trying to fund
for your upbringing right now yeah so every time you call me
i just happen to be in a very busy work call that's
supposedly funding your lifestyle my lifestyle but but dad i
haven't had dinner in a couple weeks what do you mean but
but you're having dinner now really yeah yeah exactly garden
i don't have to eat the roaches anymore this is great yeah
yeah you know like when i left you alone in the house for
four months don't worry i came back with mcdonald's and milk
dude this is so freaking worth all the trauma because i got
a happy birthday yes also do you do you remember anything
about the gameplay no no okay all right the only thing i
remember is that we were like we were like jerking off like
oh dude i'm doing that right now what do you mean this four
months i've been i'm all in game right in minecraft yeah but
yeah yeah i play this yeah yeah yeah yeah all right let's
let me boot up the game okay i still don't remember were you
the host or was i the host i remember we were having
troubles trying to boot up this pair of social fans who was
the host you remember bring up the stream bring up the
stream from four months ago who was the host of the game
because i don't know who i was the guy with the bow i don't
know who file right now oh no i don't got any simps you got
simps right i have lovely dragons oh yeah all right all
right let's i'm ruining up the game i remember we had
trouble like sending figuring out like how to get this game
running i know i think i don't think it's the game's fault i
really do think it's awesome because i know me too i think
it's like um i think we're just way too stupid to then can i
ask if you can take me to the doctor something's wrong with
me oh what's wrong there's nothing wrong with you i i took
off my wig and this started growing oh i don't know i don't
know it's it's been there for a couple days and i don't know
how to look i can't even i think oh so that's where that
went don't worry about it don't worry yeah but just Just
leave it don't worry We don't need it.
You want us to spend my hard-earned Money to take don't
worry.
It'll fall off in a couple of days It'll fall off It's just
it's just nutrients.
It's just good nutrients, you know It falls off and then and
then you just got to make sure to Eid it later so you can
get the nutrients in your system Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
That happens in nature like a chicken eating its own
Exactly.
It's like the hamsters eating the babies.
You know Do you want to hear a story about a hamster?
Yeah, what is it?
It does not involve a microwave.
Oh, apparently a story that doesn't involve a hamster story
that doesn't involve...
One of my chatters went over to his neighbor's house to
play.
Yeah.
And he was playing with slime and stuff like that.
And he noticed, he was like, he had a bad, like, what is it,
like kleptomania, like stealing.
Oh, yeah, yeah, kleptomania, yeah.
He stole a bunch of stuff from the neighbor because he was
jealous of all the toys she had.
And one of the things he stole was a little like like metal
egg on her nightstand What the fuck and there and there was
like powder in it So he put it in his kinetic sand to like
mix it in and play with it It turned out it was her her
hamsters actions.
Oh my god So he was like playing with like dead hamster
ashes basically Yeah, and like in the slime mixing it up
Wait, how did that even come up in a topic?
How did it?
Oh, I was talking about how hamsters always die in the most
ridiculous ways Like they just they don't die of old age.
They die of like walking into a How did the story even come
out?
Like, oh, they're like, hey, there's that one time I stole
my neighbor's dead hamster ashes.
I'm a lot cheaper than therapy, so they just trauma dealt
with that.
They'll be like, oh, one time, like, I don't know, one time
I got fingered behind a taco ball.
And then you're like, okay, I'm trying to play Minecraft
right now, but okay.
Guys, please come out.
So you're just like, play robes.
I was like, this is one time I stole my neighbor's dead
hamster ashes.
can't really deny it my dad loves me he's here right now
let's go i sent you an invite did you get it okay let me see
i think i did it's a theme yeah yeah yeah yeah yes i did get
it oh my god some reason it didn't pop up okay we're in oh
my god we're in oh my god it took so long for i think they
must have they must have idiot proofed this game okay so you
were the host because i have no progress it just says new
game so and there's a lock on it so i assume that you have
so you have to create the session oh frick motherfucker i
believe in us i had to be a pillow princess and do nothing
don't worry i believe in us multiplayer oh my god wait oh my
god it had that issue where like the game had no audio oh my
god it's called back to me it's all i remember all the
issues we had and then i like i somehow deleted your model
and it was off screen i couldn't grab it yeah i was like oh
my god it's all coming back to me right now oh yeah okay so
so right now there's no audio coming out from the game let
me fix that why is it at zero why are we so scuffed why is
it us every time something goes wrong oh my god it's
connected to my controller okay there you go i can play
roblox again It would just be like, JK, we're just going to
play Doors again.
I want to play, we need to play Fashion Famous.
Wait, what's that?
It's so good.
It's literally where you just dress up.
It's a fashion game.
Oh, it's basically a dress to impress.
What did I call it?
You just got, like, fashion something.
Oh, yeah, Gesture Press, that's the name of it.
Yes, yes.
It's good.
Oh, did they update anything new to it, or?
No, I'm just a man, child.
Oh, but we have to play Overwatch.
I, I, Overwatch is actually fun for the first time in like
four years.
Oh, but yeah, it's really fun now.
It's like, I, I, I think I only played it one time with the
new update.
Jetpack Cat is so fucking fun to play.
Especially when you just, you can just grab somebody's alt.
It's like, grab someone's Bob.
You don't have to ask for his permission and then like chuck
it into the enemy lines.
It's great.
Yeah, I feel like you're very Jetpack Cat coded.
Oh yeah, no.
Apparently he's been like banned every ranking.
now though because he's just too annoying to deal with i
can't do rank like overwatch players when they actually care
about winning they like put my i like my house in the house
like they post like an immature link to like my face like i
can't like you are not allowed to come back to rank do you
got like a do you know like are you in the end list on the
what there's like oh yeah so apparently there was a new
recent thing where uh people have created like an int list
where they put bounties out on streamers.
I saw that they play with the games.
Yeah.
Oh my god, yes.
You better be on that list, I bet.
I'm really getting it because I rarely touch rank.
So there's no point.
I was playing yesterday and so I was in a game and someone
went, yo, is that dokeybird?
I said yes and I laughed and I told them to subscribe to
your YouTube.
I got you, girl.
I pretended to be you.
you a subscriber nice i usually whenever they ask me like is
that dope i'll just be like no i just be like no account
yeah dude be like they're like there's no way that's the
real don't keep it and i was like you're right there is no
way i'm a cosplayer all right i'm in you're you have to set
up yeah i'm ready okay let's set up the game oh chapter
select oh yeah and then i had to count i told my chat this
but i I was smurfing on this account, just because I wanted
to play DPS on Rivals.
And then my account name is Not Doki Bird.
And then, he's like, obviously, like, who could it be?
It's Not Doki Bird.
And the guy was like, the guy was, like, asking, like, who
are you?
What's your main?
Like, why, like, what's your actual rank?
And I was just like, oh, just look me up.
And then he's like, yeah, but what's your main account's
name?
And I'm just like, bro, think about it.
it's not think of it's not dokey bird so good at shooting
you just just have no life that's just don't touch grass for
a certain amount of time and then lock yourself in i don't
have any benefits to that man i i boot up overwatch it looks
like i got parkinson's my hands are like how do you do that
gv you you spend half that day playing dress to impress no
no no no way back no it's no it was one time you spent half
that day play play roblox game yeah if you yeah you gotta
invest a hundred percent of your life to shooters there's no
taking breaks i'm dressed to impress it's all rank also the
fact that you don't touch rank that also you are not molded
yeah you're not molded with the pain and suffering grief and
blood of ring i when i play rank every time people like hate
each other so hard and i'm like guys it's like when mom and
dad Fighters, you go under your blanket playing Nintendo
Dogs on your 3DS to drown it out.
Like, I'm just like, guys!
Yes, the furry!
I was like, the mom and dad cried and she was like, no, stop
fighting!
The only way I can watch is to turn chat off.
That is the best way to play.
I do it every single time.
You know, like for me, I always tell my chat as long as they
don't slur at me, like that's a win.
Like, there's no slurs.
I was like, I was telling my chat, I was like, wow, guys, my
team is so nice, and they're like, What do you mean?
They're just saying, like, normal stuff.
I was like, yeah, they told me to kill myself, but they
didn't put a bad word in it.
I was like, yeah, guys, but they didn't slur.
So, like, the bare minimum has been achieved.
Yeah, I was, as far as the average Overwatch player goes,
that guy was pretty nice.
He told me to kill myself, but he didn't say, like, my real
name or, like, you know, or a word that would get me banned.
So.
Exactly.
As well.
He didn't, he didn't throw any, he didn't get racist.
He didn't go, get any.
He's so nice.
He didn't go say any gamer words, and he wasn't racist,
guys.
Like, that's a win in my book.
WT Vince.
Yay.
All right.
Press to play.
I'm ready.
Okay, SpongeBob.
You kind of look like SpongeBob.
And I look like Patrick.
Oh, my God.
You don't.
Get on that.
The IQs match, too.
Shut the frick.
yeah I'm not moving until you say I'm intelligent alright
guess we're gonna leave now okay I was kidding I was kidding
that's gonna go buy milk real quick oh my god how do you
remember the controls I can't how do you grip still wait
wait wait wait wait come back come back I'm gonna try to
remember something here oh I oh my god yeah we get all that
Yes, wait, wait, wait, what was it?
Oh, here you go.
Oh, now you want to know how to do it.
I shall give you the birds and the bees talk.
Wait, really?
It's time for this special talk.
I never got that talk.
I don't think I did either.
I think it's just, you know, like...
We were too busy playing video games.
I think it was just like...
uh, you go to that, what was it, the sex ed class from
school, where they divide the girls and the boys.
All they did was say, don't have sex or else you'll die, and
also, you can't, Tom.
Like, that's all I got.
That's all I got.
I think, like, all we got was just, like, this is how
periods work, and that was it.
I think I zoned out.
I was not paying attention, for sure.
I was like, I remember like... That's okay.
Coaches don't play, Ducky.
Alright, here you go.
Oh, yeah, I remember this.
This Wally.
This was what's going to...
That's what happened to Wally.
Yeah, I remember.
Where's the point?
Are we...
Oh, wait.
I remember this.
Dad, he's angry.
Oh, no.
Yeah, this is angry juice again.
Yeah.
All right.
I think we got to go to this door.
How do I pull it out?
I don't think you have a weapon.
I think you're just...
Come here.
I can protect people.
Never trust strangers!
Lesson number one!
You're my dad!
What do you mean?
Never trust your dad!
Yeah, not even me!
Why are we game journalists?
Oh, wait.
Oh, jump on the...
Yeah.
Wait, something's opening.
Maybe, like, is something open over here?
I'll check down here.
Alright, yeah, yeah.
I don't think you can...
Yeah, I'll wait.
Goodbye.
I like CSGO, like, knife surfed.
for a second on the on the pipe i'll be back i'm taking i'm
taking the all right yeah yeah don't worry i'll stay here
maybe it's a door maybe the door works now right oh yeah
maybe oh grip the handle grip the handle and like push it oh
yeah the door handle yeah yeah yeah grip that all right stop
telling me to grip things dad grip it grip it back and can i
like boost you give you a little boost get on my head okay
wait how do i no i can't do it oh wait wait i'm lost oh no
wait do you not have any special powers are you not special
i will according to okay press circle it really is oh i'm
not controlling oh okay you don't have a circle circle yeah
yeah oh oh okay okay here i'm gonna there you go and then
wait shoot shoot them shoot the people oh the people okay
never mind okay goodbye don't worry your mom and i can make
another chibi what 17 more years i can always try again yeah
we can do we can try again and make chibi too well that's
the one growing on my head is that oh wait sorry i lost
count chibi three what what sorry i lost count
I'm still freaking scared why are we game wait there is wait
there's a valve up there I think like waiting for months in
between part one and two was not the best idea but I'm not
sure yet I'm not sure if we still have to test the theory
out okay so there is a uh so there is a platform all the way
there maybe I don't think we're I should be I don't think
you're gonna make it how do i ground pound i don't think
there is a ground pound oh yeah use your wrench on the
button there's a button oh wait you're right you mean a
circular thing on the floor
all right extendo there we go boom did chat help you for
that did you look at chat did you look at chat did you not
practice critical thinking to figure that out tv look me in
the eye
don't look at me don't look at me don't look at my eye do
not look at my eyes where do we go okay so there's uh what
shoot that shoot the pipe the valve over you see the steam
yeah yeah shoot it stupid i did it i did it i did it i did
it i did it oh see that's that's what critical thinking is
chibi i i didn't look at chat and i figured out the solution
i feel like if i looked in your brain it would just be that
dancing hamster video
oh my god fall damage isn't real look see i'm alive we'll
cut that out just yeah no no i was just trying to test out
the ball damage if it's real or not all right now apparently
this game is apparently really um really short like we could
have actually just completed in one go and all right all
right now we're locking in now we're locked we were just
acting before we were acting before oh that's a woman so you
What do you do?
I asked to see her without her top on and she says, no, I
run away before she goes to the police.
That's a joke.
I'm a feminist.
I say, I hope you- Ooh, candy!
Like that told me to take this from strangers, right?
Do you remember the first lesson I taught you today?
What do you do when a stranger gives you- And take candy!
Yes!
Yay!
Good job, Gigi.
Good job.
Let's see?
Wait, there's a thing here.
Open.
I'll help you.
Okay.
Are you...
All right, grab your candy.
Yeah, I'll be there in a second.
No, frick.
Oh, but the frick are the animation.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
Why did she take you?
I don't know, maybe because somebody yelled out, take her
and said that wasn't me.
Oh, you're right.
Who could have been?
Who could have said that?
Malady.
Must have been the other voice in my head.
I swear to God, if she...
I swear to God, if she saw you, I swear to God, if she saw
you, I swear...
Oh my God.
Oh my...
Yes!
Sorry, um, no, my child.
That was really, really.
I could tell you, Karen.
Oh, my God.
Oh, are you okay?
Are you?
Thanks, Sam.
I feel good.
See it.
A girl touched me.
Oh, good for you.
You didn't cry, right?
Wait, are we supposed to go?
Are we supposed to go?
Yes, we were supposed to go!
Oh, Frank, I got scared.
Just because she's a woman and you cried the first time
doesn't mean you got to cry.
first time leave me by that dad because i think you're gonna
find out something rather embarrassing let's go all right
okay go okay go get
oh no don't go yeah she told me to come out here all right
okay wait wait let's let's take this one let's take the slow
one by one all right maybe we got a beta with this maybe
like maybe got shooter maybe I tried it went right past
there so maybe we gotta like okay is there anything is there
anything else here other wait maybe the desk you see that
desk over there yeah go get it okay chief it looked like you
didn't believe in in your old man there it was like why were
you why were you standing there why didn't you commit to it
you know if the is because this is a two this is also also
this this is also like I don't think that was a no that's
that's a solo that's a solo one man team thing that's a no
no that's a that's a one man activity right there that's a
alright listen hear me out just go in the corner like a oh
we're cocks not me I got picked I got picked not me I think
we're I think we're still in the tutorial too.
That's the worst part.
No, no, no.
I think I'd, okay, wait.
Okay, let's remember all, okay, there's the crouch.
That's crouch.
And then, okay, we can do this.
I believe in us.
Wait, I'm going to rebind crouch to see because I can't
reach the crouch.
Wait, do you not have a controller?
Have you been playing on mouse and keyboard the entire time?
That's right, that's right, baby.
Woo!
Controls.
I don't think you can rebind anything.
That's fine.
I don't need to crouch.
We don't need to do that.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Should I use my controller?
Wait, wait.
I think controller is a lot easier for these teams,
personally.
I'm crouching.
I think it was because we were running that she saw us.
So now that we're crouching, like, now she doesn't.
Yeah, yeah.
Because, like, we were so...
We were too tall, you know?
So now... Now, you go first.
Oh, okay.
You go first?
Because then she'll see you...
Yeah, and then...
Dude, I can't stop looking at her shadow.
It looks like...
And then after...
Don't give up!
Help.
You see, the reason why you got caught is that you didn't
listen to my instructions.
Can you show me how to do that?
Okay, yeah, yeah, sure.
I'm a visual learner.
All right, so after you finish, after you're done crouching,
all right, you see her do that?
All right.
and then where do we go after maybe up those the dresser
right there those he looks like you can climb that okay wait
how long does she stay behind yeah let's see what she does
yeah yeah yeah oh oh no she's like what's that smell oh okay
now no no no no get her get her no i mean get me
me all right so what the so now we know okay so we wait see
look look at your old man i'm doing when you killed me in
apex hide and seek do you remember that you're pretending to
be my friend and then you just gunned me down that was me
motherfucker i don't know if you remember that are you sure
are you sure that was the this are you sure that was me are
you sure it could have been anyone that was you it could
have been anybody there's you know how many people you know
you could have the same username in apex legends uh with
other people that you is there's no unique usernames you
know there i could have been it could have been anyone that
did that i would never your old dad would never my distrust
with woman began with you okay go behind her all right i
followed you like a duckling go under the desk all right all
right and then she has no idea there's no way she knows
we're down here There's no way.
She has no peripheral vision.
And then, yeah, yeah.
And then we go to the dresser.
Yeah, we climb up this thing.
Or the door.
What do we do?
No, I don't think.
I think it's stress.
I think...
I think I got it.
I think we went the wrong way.
Oh, maybe we go in our office to the left, maybe?
She came out of there?
I don't think the door was open.
The door was very, very close.
And we're very, very small people.
Okay, speak for yourself.
I'm six foot.
what are you really all right here you go oh yeah that door
is just is shut shut there it's very close yeah my fault all
right i'm sniffing your wrench
did you ask consent first before oh well i said this was a
one person activity all right
that's what you get for getting distracted you do it after
oh yeah it's a celebration yeah after to celebrate okay
should we stay maybe maybe she won't look under her desk
yeah you're right gamers don't look down where's she going
she has no idea but we're oh we're so dumb we're so okay
we're so freaking dumb we're like objectively so freaking
dumb all right now we get this over yeah all right i'll turn
around so you have your private tab and then also i have my
own private oh already all right listen she had six arms i'm
into that you know what they say of a lady with six arms
that's right Every hole Alright Oh Wait that's us Hey Oh
shit Oh my god It's like those Like Those amusement parks
Where they have like a little Camera You're in the middle of
the ride And we have to smile at the camera You know they
like charge you now What I do is every time I ride those
They've always charged you What do you mean?
Wait really?
Oh They've never Oh what They've never been That's right I'm
6 foot I'm 6 foot Come on and open it no i'm i'm just
stretching how are you supposed to do no wait wait no no no
don't you're not six foot you don't get ow oh wait i think
we're oh oh wait can you oh no oh wait okay okay wait maybe
it's because of the um maybe that we have to push this oh
yeah yeah maybe with that painting or something looks like
it's like lit up maybe I gotta shoot it no no why do I even
have free will oh see that's why I'm here yeah use your
thinking abilities let's see what is over here who just said
this is my baby picture what's up wait which one which one
you told me you're my dad I think I think it's you know your
chibi how many chibis have we been three right now that
that's chibi one that's chibi two no are you kidding we
don't talk about this chibi we don't talk about her maybe
maybe she didn't make enough ad revenue on twitch she'd be
put down we just took her to a farm upstate for real oh
that's so good yeah yeah yeah yeah What the fuck?
Why are we so dumb?
Like, it's just like...
No, no.
We're warming up.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're warming up right now for the real gameplay.
We gotta save.
We gotta save our brain cells for the real gameplay part of
the game.
I want to shoot the camera, but it doesn't let me.
Like father, like son.
There has to be some...
Maybe something in this placenta.
Maybe, like, wait, no, we have to, but you see that, you see
that little crack on the wall?
Yeah, yeah, so I feel like we have, oh my god.
I have an idea, I think we need to move this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you see the handle on the little thing?
You got it, you got it.
All right, here we go.
See, you're, like, your old men, your real men's, I am your
father.
I'm sorry.
I, I, I, I'm sorry.
sorry i i think we gotta i think we gotta set you back to
the to the happy place i think i won't i won't anymore you
remember the happy place your mama and i sent you where's my
mom did you take the medication that your your new friend
gave you yeah the guy in the white coat Yeah, yeah, yeah,
your new best friend.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did you remember to take them?
Yeah, they make me think you're here when you aren't.
It's great.
Oh, big!
Ah!
You- I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm- All right.
Cheeby for her.
Chee-be for her.
Where are you?
Hello, it is I!
Maybe with- With every new Chee-be.
Their IQ increased by at least 1%.
That's actually a really big number.
Watch out for the spicy water.
It's like a McDonald's spray.
Alright, Chi, before, when you see this, what is your first
thing you want to do in your head?
I'm going to hit that circle.
Boom!
Alright, it's safe to go.
Okay, then go.
Okay.
you sorry I'm just I'm just testing what we don't just go
it's fine oh I'll turn around I'll come with you we could
walk back to the
I just, you gotta walk past, you know, memory lane.
Remember when we were here for 15 minutes?
Oh, yeah, I don't remember.
Remember when we could have passed this level 15 minutes
ago?
We literally just had to hide.
Do you have ADHD?
I want to say no, but then my fans say yes.
My fans, no, my fans also say no.
So I think you got it from your mom.
Oh, who's my mom?
I don't know, but I'm sending those checks somewhere.
They better be going somewhere.
Oh, big!
Okay, let's try and hide.
Let's go, big girl!
Okay, let's try and hide this time.
Okay.
Oh, hey, look.
We don't have to do the walk of shame.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
i killed myself instead of you what oh wait you died on my
screen you lived what no i lived i just watched you i
watched it happen mother fricker did you learn anything did
you learn anything new from that i did i'm sorry i'll behave
now all right here we go ramos so are you um are you a
chicken more like a chocobo a giant ass chocobo so that
means you're half chicken so if they if you cut that
explains the eggs yeah so you like cut yourself in half it
tastes like chicken all right do you think she'll i don't
think she'll leave i think we're supposed to go under that
table oh oh oh that's awkward at least you're wanted she
goes for you every time it ignores me.
It's like, ew, that one stinks like an Arby's beef each
other.
I don't want that one.
Don't worry.
One day someone will want you.
Really?
One day.
It might take years.
It might take years, but one day...
I'm stuck.
It might cost a lot of money, but one day we'll get there.
Well, one day, one day we'll get there.
When she gets over there, we go to the table.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think so, especially when, you know, we sat there and then
she turned around and grip me i'm gonna path i'm going now
all right she has no idea she's not in the way she was like
it's snoo-snoo time did you say it's snoo-snoo time yeah you
gotta go this way do you know what snoo-snoo is yeah i just
watched that future drama episode oh wait i think it's one
oh wait unless you're lucky i'm built like a freaking stick
bug okay i don't know where
that?
How do you think you were conceived?
You used to my mom's buff?
I didn't know you were based like that.
Alright.
I think we go where the toilet paper is.
Maybe we'll wait until we wait until she goes back over
there.
Where do we go?
No, I think...
Is there like a door over there?
A far, right?
No, that door is definitely closed, closed.
She's kind of beautiful.
Yeah, she didn't so bad.
All right, go.
I can't move.
Donkey!
I'm going to check out this over here.
I got time.
I know you're time!
Ah, frick!
You with your six arms!
But I thought that's what you were into.
A lady with six arms.
I mean, like, if she was a little bit more gentle.
Well.
Oh.
So you're vanilla.
I'm going to things about you that are that are making me
concerned i was conceived by snoo-snoo and then you're not
vanilla what the is happening put it on the wiki
all right
all right go
i i got so excited i tried to sprint for no reason i just i
i have an objective it's like you threw a stick yeah i said
Go and you're like, okay.
Go, go, go.
And you're like, go, go?
All right, here we go.
I'm sick of...
What did we just do with our...
Oh my god, oh my god, we were like hovering.
We were like playing patty cake with our feet.
A.L.
All right, let's go.
All right.
You say when.
You've a better...
You've a better everything.
Okay, okay.
Don't worry, eventually you'll pass down.
You're just a late bloomer.
That's what everyone says.
It's getting really, really late, but don't worry.
Eventually.
Yeah, I'm going to be 30 one day, and it's, you know.
We're getting to a point, you know.
I feel like, you know, I think it is that far, right?
Because you climbed it.
Yeah, there was like a thing over there.
Yeah, go climb.
Go.
Okay.
Woo-hoo!
Yippee!
Oh, the cubby, the cubby-o!
The cubby-o!
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
Just go up, just go up, just go up, just go up.
She doesn't know.
She's black.
How can she conceive what she cannot see?
All right.
Conceive?
Wait, how can she conceive?
Yeah.
She is kind of old.
I feel like the egg basket is kind of empty.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure she's on menopause right now.
She ovulates.
It's like being calm.
Okay, wait.
What's over there?
I'm like on like a bunch of girders.
Okay, what's what?
What are you doing?
I'm not the rat!
okay oh my god i'm gonna throw it down oh never mind i'm
keeping it i love it i put it in my butt all right all right
what's going on up there i need i need visuals it's actually
really nice up here nothing's happening all right so that
means i have to go oh yeah yeah there's there's a hole here
you gotta come up here all right what if you go up go
through that hole and see if i get magically transported
yeah magically tp'd okay okay okay i'm going down okay now
i'm in a room with a lever.
Okay.
I don't think I can reach it without you.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm heading over.
Alright, I can't see you, but I believe in you.
Alright, don't worry.
Your old man's got this.
This ain't my first rodeo.
Oh, wait.
It's really nice up here.
Yeah, right.
It's like relaxing.
There's no, like, monsters.
Yeah.
This place ain't so bad.
Wait, did you go Where did you go?
I went to the right.
There's like a tunnel.
Oh, okay.
I see it.
I see the little tunnel.
Alright, don't worry.
Daddy's coming.
Oh, daddy hit her head.
Alright.
Oh, there's another hole in the hole.
There you are.
Look, see?
I did it.
That's right.
We're so good at this game.
Alright, I think...
We have to...
There's nothing else we can grip here?
Yeah.
I think we might need to take you back to...
Don't!
We're gonna have to see Mr. Harris.
No!
His hands are so cold!
Okay.
We're so dumb.
We can't even get a...
There must be something.
Wait.
Let me see.
I don't think I can whack that.
Is there anything wackier?
Yeah, get that door You're strong, independent I'm whacking
everything If you've hit something enough Maybe you're
League of Legends player Oh, I never touch the That's the
one game I just told myself I don't have that much mental
health issues You know, they're planning on adding a voice
chat to it And I was like, oh my god Oh my god I You wanna
jump on my head?
I don't think I'm supposed to do that
Nice, I got it there we go all right wait try shooting it
you not shoot it i did i it doesn't all right wait i but
like we shoot anything up here no whenever friends don't let
friends play league of legends this is a psa
psa okay there must be something we can do god it's like
every like this is like an iq test We just fail every level.
No, no, no, no.
There's no time limit.
You can't fail if, like...
Oh, yeah.
You can't fail.
We don't give up.
Exactly, exactly.
We already got one point.
We put our name down.
Okay, wait.
Wait, I have an idea.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought of...
I was thinking about that, too.
Maybe you're stronger than me.
I'll try.
Okay.
No.
Maybe the other one.
The other one?
Or that.
Oh, there you go.
It moves.
It's moving.
I swear to God, I see it moving.
Really?
Okay, I'll keep out of it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep doing it.
It was moving.
Shoot the lever!
Maybe we'll push forward?
Oh, maybe it's like...
That's like Meet the Robins...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's push, not pull.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One time I went to a Starbucks as a kid, and, like, I
read...
You know, like, they have glass doors.
Sometimes I, like, full frontal slam my forehead into it.
Okay, but to be fair, it's very transparent.
though it could happen to anybody yeah like you know like if
birds come on birds slam through windows all the time
exactly i feel so bad when it happens you know birds are
very smart creatures yeah so if it can happen to a bird it
can happen to anybody yeah glass is so like even like my
dogs have run into them yeah exactly i try to see your dogs
are stupid no of course not exactly exactly you're just as
smart as a dog be proud of that thank you thank you well i
didn't call you a furry but you but you were you were the
one that brought it up first why did you bring it up first
surely surely They can't just put us in a room forever!
A rubber room!
Even my child won't even tell me because they don't know.
We're all so dumb.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, apparently you're supposed to crouch and I jump from
you.
There's no way that's how it works.
I don't...
Wait, there was a moment.
Wait.
lift up what does that mean lift up oh you gotta like hold
your handy and then wait maybe wait okay hold my head okay
hold your hand oh oh my oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
look at I engage um oh look have you started oh you hit the
gritty oh oh oh oh look look see oh whoa why the frick you
grabbed me like a subway sandwich you sick mother i will
guys guys this is not like guys we it's been four months
since we played this game it's not our fault that we forgot
it's not our fault that we forgot that we forgot all the
controls guys i was stuck in
Oh, you want to be the upies?
Yeah, upies.
All right, go, go, go, go.
All right, we gotta go fast.
We gotta go fast.
Pretend you drive it.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
That's okay, fault damage isn't real.
I got feather falling.
We're good.
Oh my god.
I have the water bucket.
I got the water bucket.
Did you see it?
That was sick.
Did you clip it?
You had one job, Chibi.
I gave you the camera to clip daddy's cool new trick.
Come on, get the camera.
Oh.
Oh, got the light.
Oh, that might have been a bad idea.
That might have been a really...
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, wait.
Okay, they can't come to us.
Okay, yeah, we just gotta...
All right.
Oh, we gotta stay together.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta stay together.
Yeah.
Ew, I don't like this.
Oh, this is...
They're tickling my toes.
It's like those little fishies that like you used to hear a
feed in and then they start nibbling your toes.
No, but...
All right, here.
We go up here.
But like you could eat the little dead skin.
Yeah, yeah, they eat the little dead skin off your toes.
Oh.
Hey, Dad.
There's more bugs.
Wait, there must be like...
Oh, wait, shoot that bucket.
You see that bucket?
Bucket?
No, he doesn't want him.
All right, here.
Come on, come over here, come over here.
Come on.
Upies.
Look at that.
Teamwork.
Go, go, go, go.
Father, daughter, teamwork right here.
See, we can work together.
We can.
Yeah, see.
Hey, you come to this event often?
They always do that.
Sorry, wrong door.
Wrong...
Oh, you didn't even need to go in it.
Wrong door.
Well, that's...
I'm going to goomba-stomp you.
Come here.
Ah!
Oh.
All right.
Yeah, I'm winning.
Why didn't you live that?
Yay.
Oh, God.
There's so much meat everywhere.
Where are you?
I'm coming.
I've been waiting for you.
I'm like way ahead right now.
what the frick dude look at this guy this is like how they
watch our stream this is the future of me too big right here
twitch oh yeah yeah I was I saw that like a long time ago
you're like really far away what see if you didn't jump if
you didn't jump you could have seen the stuff I'm seeing
right now see that's like a good that's like an anti like
suicide message yeah don't jump yeah Where the fuck are you?
What do you mean?
I'm like, I'm like at the end.
I'm there just waiting for you.
Yeah.
Where are you?
I'm stuck in a room.
You're stuck in a room?
I'm past the room.
But it's locked.
Oh, I think we bugged it.
I think we bugged it because you were so far away.
You are a disgusting creature.
I'm on the other side right now.
What does the door look like?
It's like, it's a fucking door.
What do you mean?
I'm past that room.
It's not a door.
What is it?
It's a fucking room with a door.
What do you mean?
What's in the room?
Oh, there, oh, the rug fixed.
Oh, it glit.
It fixed.
See, there's a door.
I told you.
I got teleported back here.
Oh, that's okay.
That's not your fault, please.
Yeah.
See?
I fell down.
You were so scared.
silence about it because i thought that oh oh i'm i'm
swimming with my mouth open right now um five second rule
i'm pretty sure this is longer than five seconds how long
has this candy been here you ever had like sugar-free candy
like poop your pants what yeah also why would you have if
you want candy why would you just just commit to sugar sugar
candy why would you do like don't bird is anti-diabetes look
at this oh yeah my dad my dad's diabetic so like we have a
lot of like non-sugar candy wait what do you mean you're
dead that's me i'm diabetic oh freak you are you not don't
keep your mouth shut wait wait i'm i'm you've been giving me
sugar-free candy this entire time you've i'm just helping
your bowel movements this is how i find out a sip of coffee
and you like run to the bathroom to poop oh yeah yeah yeah
coffee yeah i don't drink a lot of caffeine because of it
yeah i have to poop so much what's over there some bugs oh
that is so bad i don't like them well i don't think you
think they like you invading dirt space too that's true we
are yeah they're just trying to have a family meal they're
trying to spend time with family like what we're doing right
now exactly like what we're doing right now yeah we're
getting taco bell after this right um shortcut boom oh all
right don't worry i'll don't worry after this i'll go i'll
go out and grab us taco bell all right and you'll come back
yeah yeah yeah i'll come back oh nice diabetic my diabetic
father go eat some candy they're sugar-free right oh there's
a oh there's There we go, we jump together.
Yeah, the power of friendship.
Yeah.
Okay, we can't even find this.
Oh, don't.
I gotta stop thinking.
Like, quick, Chibi.
Eat more candy, then it'll...
Fuck up.
Fuck up right now.
No, let's go.
All right.
So you come to this event often?
Don't turn around.
Don't turn down.
You gotta learn to get better at losing.
chibi i have good risk i have like the kind of risk like uh
what's your success rate
dude you say you had good risk i i when was the last time it
worked you got you can't just run away from your problems
chibi yeah you'll never improve if you never learn see this
is why your mother and i worried about you you've been alone
for a very long time are you freddy dazbear because i want
to put a kid in you did you just try to kill yourself i
heard something see i'm trying to show you what happens you
see i could have been a very nice lady who uh you might have
had a chance and now look what you did she's dead now are
you coming i think you're on top of the vent No?
Look, Chibi, I know you really liked all those candies out
there, but I think you might need to chill out with the
candy.
All right, I'll go play with this sausage.
You want her?
Here's for you.
You can have her.
It's really good.
Oh no, this is creepy.
Alright, I gotta shoot this boot me.
Alright.
Bip!
My lady.
Yeah.
Oh, it's very cold out here.
Wait, the sausage are people.
What?
Oh my god.
There's no way we'd be eating people in Little Nightmares.
That would never happen.
Exactly.
That's never happened in any version of Little Nightmares.
No, never.
It's a very wholesome game.
Exactly.
I can't believe they would introduce in my comfort game.
Motherfucker, I know you got arthritis.
Go faster.
Mother, mother, mother.
You say it nicely, Cheeby.
Remember what we taught you.
Please, what?
Please go escalator.
Please go to escalator.
Okay, I know what the last word means.
You can't just speak a different...
What does it mean?
different language thinking you could get away with
achieving I think I know what puta means all right up we go
let's go don't don't yeah I get to keep the college money
then i dropped out of college i went and then i made two
dollars on twitch and i dropped out there's a lot of
conversation with my mom to be fair that's better than debt
to be fair following your old man's footsteps are you are
you where are you gonna come up i've been gone my guy just
did a backflip when are you when you're coming up i've been
i've been waiting for you
I think I'm lagging.
It won't let me in.
Oh, there we go.
I fixed it.
I think my internet went out.
Yay, yay, yay, you're in here that one.
Oh, wait, what's over here?
That's a big-ass hug, but you know what they say about
big-ass...
Sorry, I shouldn't speak about grandma like that.
What did you say about grandma?
What did you say?
I don't want another death by school.
it's tv time oh break it maybe i can yeah no i no it's
unbreakable put nickelodeon on oh you don't know about what
happened nickelodeon i do but oh my god okay i did okay now
i know what happened are we in the nickelodeon hotel right
now you know i went like three times as a kid wait the
nickelodeon hotel yeah they like slimy and stuff it's
freaking yeah i was just yeah like were you on okay funny
story i always have the i was in the sponge bob room and the
first night i pissed at them what how old were you like
about like like 10 maybe 8 like you know oh all right lower
your meat i think you gotta lower your meat i think i got
yeah i got wait for the other way back wait throw it back oh
okay no no there's one more there's one oh there you go all
right goodbye bye i'm going to the nickelodeon hotel
Why did you let go?
I thought maybe I was above something.
I got tired.
I got really...
You got tired?
I was just taking my smoke break.
Oh, yeah.
Your daddy needs smoke breaks every once in a while.
Yeah, I was wondering why you always smell like cigarettes.
Yeah, it's okay.
I only smoke in front of you.
I know, with the windows, Bob.
You hot box with the kid in the car.
All right, I go.
Oh.
I missed!
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm good.
It's okay.
I'm watching everything that's happening right now.
Me and my buddies.
Me and my...
It's okay.
We're gonna get in Jackass.
You know Jackass is coming back.
I've never seen that show.
Don't worry.
You're gonna be in that show soon.
Really?
Alright, what do you see, Chibi?
Um, I'm in a room with a light bulb.
Yeah?
I'm gonna take it.
Take the light bulb.
I don't I gotta go through I'm in the tunnel with the fan Oh
okay oh oh they turned off the fan Oh I'm just watching okay
so that's what I'm watching what you're doing right now
through the TV And oh no okay okay you Alright good nice you
got the throw Yeah yeah I see you Alright you fell down
You're turning around You're you're standing there Are you
jerking off Are you are you jerking Are you I got a virus on
my PC There's a virus so I stood up My pants fell down.
It was a virus.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It could have happened to anyone.
Alright, we got one of the legs.
All right, here we go.
Yeah.
My mom is very worried about this particular addiction you
have.
Really?
Wait, we're a little worried.
You haven't been out of your room for a couple of days now.
but i think i'm pretty sure i got it up up there you go that
was so smart take that that's for you oh what the is going
up there you see that tv yeah yeah i think he's doing
inventory oh yeah he's checking yeah he's checking the he's
doing inventory right now he's doing his good oh i think
he's gonna be oh we all we're gonna be uh gonna say hello to
him do our grocery run oh oh are you oh oh all right chibi
five it's it's that oh all right chibi five you're time for
you to come up come out of the basement chibi five hello
good ants in my pants all right chibi five careful you need
depth of perception to walk across that All right.
Be careful.
It's hard.
Ladies first.
Oh, quit.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
She's in the future.
Okay.
The score sheet.
Oh, there's...
I think we dropped down?
Yeah, I think so, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a hole here.
You know what they say about holes.
That they're holes?
If there's a hole, there's a goal.
Yeah, you're learning.
Yeah, I'm so proud of you.
I feel so smart.
Oh, yeah, I think I have the...
I think it's boosting time.
Oh, dude.
Come on.
Well, I'm boosted in every game I play, so...
Oh, freak!
Wait, do you see what I mean right there?
Yeah, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have plenty of alt accounts.
Oh, I die, I got it.
It's okay.
I have another alt account.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay, hop on that donkey bird.
All right.
There we go.
Okay.
All right, there we go.
Oh, we have to go back, too.
Here, catch it.
You gotta catch it, okay?
Catch.
All right, don't worry.
Did you get it?
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
Okay.
Oh, we gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go, we
gotta, we gotta, we gotta, we gotta, we gotta, we gotta, we
gotta, we gotta, we gotta, we gotta, have you seen, have you
seen a dead body before, GB?
Yeah, I used to live in Chicago.
See this?
My dad.
Or no, my uncle.
I've seen a few.
Oh, your mom's new best friend, right?
Yeah.
Where do we go?
Oh, maybe you jump up right here and then I throw this to
you?
No, it's right here.
Oh, you're so freaking intelligent.
Yeah, I bet your mom's new best friend wouldn't know how to
do that.
You mean my mom's best friend?
Yeah, your mom's new buddy.
I'm my mom's best friend because I'm cool like that.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Y'all slow down.
Patience.
back up back up here i'm a freaking r slash nice guy come on
this way princess all right i'm here wait wait princess
princess okay there you go i forgot sorry my legs my knees
don't work like they used to it's okay it's okay i was about
to make it there i was gonna say a lot of bending down in
your day yeah that's right that's right
speedrunning we've gone oh look at that see I told you we
were okay it's okay it's okay we can still get on speedrun
.com we can still get on speedrun.com it's just we can fix
it just a little minus five seconds all right here you go
don't worry this room would have taken us 15 minutes earlier
yeah yeah yeah yeah now look okay okay come on in oh you you
like to be yeah yeah yeah yeah I do the yuppies.
That's a man's job.
I want to squish myself.
Oh, we're going up.
Where are we going?
I have no idea what this story is about, by the way.
I have no idea.
The only one that, like, I understood the story was Little
Nightmares 2.
I think I understood Little Nightmares 1 and 2.
Well, one I felt like it was more of, like, an experience.
the second one had such a like cool story i really liked it
right oh someone's failing their class i had a nightmare
about being in college again do you ever have nightmares
like that like all the time just about being in god dude
yeah i have like a nightmare that my mom signed me up for
five classes and i'm like mom i i have a job and she's like
no you need to go you go go take economics too oh no not
economics too oh all right outside Wait, I think it's here.
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
Follow me, Princess.
Would you take the red pill or the blue pill?
Would you jump for...
Would you take the raw chicken or jump for the beef?
You seem like a beef kind of girl.
You jump for the cooked beef?
Yeah, of course we jump for the beef.
Yeah, you take the risk.
Exactly.
Everyone goes for the raw chicken, though.
Yeah, but all those others are NPCs.
No, no, I'm okay.
See?
I'm okay.
I got you something.
those who take the chicken oh oh oh it's because the camera
seat is a those who take the chicken they oh it hits right
here it's right here i can't shoot their mpcs all right
ladies first oh oh yeah yeah oh they got all these movies oh
oh my god there's movie chat okay it's just a camera don't
worry okay wait uh i gotta go up there i see oh sorry i
hugged you we got to pull this out like you should have done
with my mom oh big okay you're okay so yeah that's what
happened when me and your mom
thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you all right
thank you queen all right i'll be back i was just re
recreating a wonderful experience this guy's got a gaming
setup in here All right, open the door.
Knock, knock.
Daddy's waiting.
Do you hear daddy knocking?
Yeah, I'm scared.
Let me in, Chibi.
Why are you hiding in that room?
Oh, I see where to go.
I think I gotta go.
How do I climb up there?
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm so smart.
I'm scared the knocks are getting louder.
You only make me stronger, Chibi.
What do I get?
What do I get from the mom?
Did you hear that?
Yes, I feel you breaking it by.
I know I broke that into your mom.
No!
I got that from Jessica.
My mom?
Okay, move this.
Sure, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's your mom's second.
That's her nickname, you know?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like such a freaking game journalist right now.
the thing is there is a camera in that room and i don't know
where you are at right now i'm in a game or set you're right
i do not even see you on the cap no i there's i think you're
supposed to open the toy for me i just can't i can't reach
it if you can pull this off if you put your mind to it you
can do anything never give up it's working keep going oh my
god up.
Never back down.
Never what?
Surrender!
Never back down.
Never what?
Surrender!
Never!
Wait, now where do I go?
I moved something, but I don't want to go.
Wrong way.
I pushed it the wrong way.
I can end the speech again.
I can't see it.
I can't move it.
It's not.
Just pull up your VOD and rewind to that one.
Daddy's tired now.
Guys, I'm just the wrong way and it's stuck.
I can't.
What do you mean?
It's stuck.
I'm not meditating.
Oh, the door opened.
Why did the door open?
It's because the cat is because like...
Come in.
What?
Come on.
All right.
Pull this.
Pull this for me.
All right.
Let me see what you...
saw in that room it's a gaming setup okay all right i'm
watching you on the tv oh yeah oh i see that door and i
think you're supposed to move okay and then okay back up no
no back up back up yeah back up yeah you backing up up all
right yeah okay there's a tv in the door all right back up
wait wait there is all right now you push the tv you push
the tv for me i i can't my my brittle arms can't move it
maybe you push it and i push it i wait i can't pull wait i
can't i I think I boofed it.
I pushed it the wrong way.
Wait, okay, back up.
Yeah, maybe keep pushing it in.
I think we fucked up.
Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
I think we actually...
I think we might have...
You're running over there?
I got this.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's your turn.
We take turns.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Alright, I'm pushing.
Okay.
I'm pushing it.
Push it.
I'm also pushing it.
Yeah.
Okay, let go, let go.
Yeah, I'm letting go.
I'm so freaking weak.
Alright.
The moment I come over, it's gonna close.
It's gonna.
dumb.
Like, actually.
No, no, we're not dumb.
There's no time limit.
I was saying time.
There's no time.
We haven't submitted the results yet.
We don't know yet.
That's true.
We haven't gotten an answer.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we can't.
We can't be dumb if there's no answer.
I think...
Do we have to reset it?
Wait, keep pushing?
Okay, I'm I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
I'm pushing.
Wait, maybe?
Oh, hitting it doesn't work.
What the frick, you just walked in?
How did you do that?
You just walked in, you freaking wizard.
I thought...
How did you do that?
I thought you tried to walk in, and then you said it's
stuck.
So in my head, I thought this option was already...
I thought...
No, no, we're smart.
We're smart.
We beat the puzzle.
Cheeby, I...
I thought you already tried this option.
And then...
And then in my head, I was like, maybe she didn't try this
option.
Your breasts smell like chicken.
Get out of my face.
Let's go.
Let's go get up.
No, no, no, no.
No, no.
Okay.
Yeah, you got your job.
That's your job.
No, no.
Okay, that's all over.
Okay.
First try.
Remember when you were like, I can't fit through?
So I was like, you can't fit through?
Oh, I guess that wasn't.
If I upload this playthrough to YouTube, I'm gonna, we're
gonna crawl so many slurs.
Like they're gonna be like, oh my god, do this quickly.
And they're kind of right too, because we should have done
that.
I think this TV got overcooked a little bit.
Now you sound like my real dad.
What do you mean real dad?
My dad doesn't...
The one who, like, you know, the dad that stepped up.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your mom's new best friend.
Yeah, they play fight a lot.
Did they talk about me?
Yeah, sometimes.
Yeah, what do they say?
They say nice things, right?
They say the check came in.
That's about it.
Wait, do we... Oh wait, wait, I dropped down.
Oh, no.
It's so funny how they grab us.
She's like grabbing like a little burrito.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Your turn.
All right, I got this.
Dude, I'm walking all dubiously.
Look at my tippy toes.
They are not suspicious.
Not not suspicious.
Don't be suspicious.
just okay i'm gonna let's see what her like her route is
maybe when she's like not near oh oh she's freaking out oh
we should have waited trail okay let's go down here there's
a there's a thing where's the oh there's thing all right
good job moly right we're on the other side oh oh
really have the sign is it because she's she never found a
husband oh or wait what do you mean a woman what are you
trying well no i mean like sometimes i get mad because i
sometimes like i'm like man oh oh oh she's a spider she got
a knob now to make it oh what the fuck yeah what happened to
her ass shake it when i say i want a woman that's all ah
that's what i mean i don't she even has ass no more that
does not look that's just that's just like a bulb there's
another mug it's right here i gotta climb the shelves catch
don't worry i'm coming back from milk milk god you god we
keep drinking through all this milk so fast is this like the
normal pathway to get Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's only one road, you know?
There's only one road to get it.
There's so much traffic, and there's, like, people trying to
eat us.
Exactly, exactly.
Milk is very high in demand.
We gotta keep growing, you know?
I'm gonna touch your butt.
You better run.
I'm coming.
Why'd you speed up?
You're like, I've never been sprinting in the tunnels until
that moment.
I saw a bug, you know?
I saw a bug right behind me.
Oh, you did?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, freak, I put something in here.
I put a wall in there.
Did you lay eggs?
Sorry, the discard...
Oh, the discard call dropped.
What do you say?
Oh, I said, do you lay eggs?
Oh, man, we gotta change the server for this call.
You're, like, cutting in and out for me.
Are you popping one right now?
That's not why.
It's okay.
Like, I...
Most women lay eggs.
What's coming out of that pipe is your egg?
Oh.
Okay, we gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go,
actually, we gotta go, motherfucker, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, take her, take her, take her, yeah, that's, that was so
messed up, I was a victim, oh, sorry, I was lagging, what's,
what happened?
Wait, really?
You're actually lagging?
Yeah, yeah, I was actually lagging this.
No, I was actually lagging.
I kept teleporting on the screen.
That's okay, that's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hop in your alt.
All right, here we go.
You got this.
All right, you go, you go?
All right, don't worry, teamwork.
Woo-hoo!
Yay!
Hold the lady!
Wait, I'm really far behind.
I'm scared of it.
Don't worry, I'm really far behind.
Where do we go?
Oh, crotch, crotch, crotch, crotch, crotch, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
The core!
Take the jump!
Oh, wait, crouch?
Oh, my God.
Wait, you can slide?
Oh, Fekka is a 10%
dancer!
I'm just pushing you from the back.
I'm, like, crawling.
Keep crawling.
There, see what we- That was actually so scary.
She's right behind us.
Is she?
Oh no, nothing personal.
We're skinny legends.
Those Zen picks working.
It's a shame I'm going blind in 10 years though.
Oh, we gotta hide.
Hide.
She's no idea.
There's no way.
I think she knew.
Ew, I don't like her knob.
It's so gross.
Not to body shame.
Maybe we go left.
Maybe there's like somewhere to go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Elevator tab.
Elevator.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, see, that's how you get in fact.
I don't know how it took you 20 years.
Alright, what do we do in that room?
I'm not trying to be mean, but she's really freaking ugly
now.
Hey, respect your elders.
That's gonna happen to you one day.
That's it in, like, five years.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get a BBL and, like, a facelift, though, so I'll
look good.
I'll look like the love is blind contestants.
I'll look really good.
Oh, yeah, maybe over here.
I don't think so I think we're actually supposed to Come
here come here Come here
I was very wrong I was Oh go go go I was really caught Oh my
god Don't worry Don't worry we just love watching this
cutscene so much Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we just wanna We
just wanna see her do that again again all right uh where
should we go i do you think to the right i that's i feel
like you can crawl under there to the left maybe like
where's that good you can't you can't i was wrong again i
was wrong again now frank i thought maybe there was like
another room or something How does she notice me first?
Do I stink?
I think, like, I think she noticed you first because you
have been, you have been, like, you know, judging her, you
know.
Oh, yeah, maybe it's like, yeah.
Yeah, I think it's personal.
I think, I think you, you didn't, uh, what was it called?
Ding dong ditched too many times.
I've never done that.
Sure.
I did on accident one time.
I'll just say, that's what they all say.
I was on a cruise ship.
I can't get in.
I can't get out.
I can't.
Oh my gosh.
She's right.
She's she's right.
She's right above me Where are we going?
I don't know Okay, get it.
I'm stuck.
No, it's fake.
Don't crouch down.
Crouch down.
Oh, you right You right.
Hey guys.
Did you guys enjoy that cut?
What if we watch that cut scene again?
Guys, it's like a Quizlet.
How many are?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, there's something Did you notice something different
in the newest cutscene?
It circled, the different It is.
Wow, yeah, there's a pamphlet.
You gotta fill out this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a little questionnaire.
There's a little quiz after this cutscene.
Alright, you leave the way.
I'm gonna follow you, okay?
Oh.
Yeah, we crouch in the corner?
Yeah, this time we crouch in the corner.
And we don't move us.
Okay.
and don't move.
I don't feel good about...
Wait, I see boxes we could climb.
I see on the left, those boxes.
You see on the left, there's like a box there.
There was?
Wait, I did not see the box.
Okay, okay.
I'll show you.
I don't think it's right, but I think it's worth a shot.
I don't understand.
We're in the dark.
How could she see us?
She has all her shoes.
eyes your eyesight gets worse the older you get how could
she see yeah how could she see it she's practically
half-blind do you wear glasses yeah i do actually yeah i
fucked up my eyesight from gaming too much that's that's
actually a watchtale thankfully no no it's wrong you don't
go here you don't go here you don't go here but that's
that's death under there look we're so dumb oh my dumb we're
so dumb i live these wait she does look wait she does look
left first yeah wait were you crouching when you were hiding
in in the shelf okay well
balls oh my god this casino is so good i could watch it one
more time i wish it was longer i know right i know all right
lead the way queen okay what do we both go to the left
really really fast.
Okay.
And then we crouched down.
But also, I want to watch the cutscene again, though, after
this.
What do you think?
Yeah, me too.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really want to see it again.
Yeah.
The way it wiggles is so cool.
I know, like, especially when she, like, grabs us.
Okay, crouch and don't— Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She has no idea.
She might change, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She has no idea, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Wait?
We're so freaking dumb.
Oh, my God.
We're so smart.
it's okay it's okay there's a rat it's okay oh fickle rat
see it chibi i knew that shelf idea was the right idea i'm
you should have listened to me in the first place when i
told you i told you to go under that shelf but it's okay we
all make we all make mistakes here yeah and some name
oh my god oh okay oh yeah yeah and then i think yeah and i
just got I pushed the cart all the way up and then you just
You promised us the cutscene Look Sorry we Sorry we saw it
was a new cutscene So we were so like We were just Just clip
it and go watch it I can't just clip it and go back to it
I mean not yet Not yet, not yet It's sparking right now
Wait, wait five seconds I can't push any more beat all right
nice and then all right jump up and do the left no oh yeah
yeah all right i'm taking you to the circus don't worry i'll
come back this is where i was conceived very good memories
yeah all right oh maybe you gotta i'm up no wait no i can't
oh you gotta help me do i yeah i think so I don't think so.
Oh no.
I can't do it.
Oh, you're twerking though.
Yeah, I can't do it.
Are you sure we can't?
I'm too weak.
Oh yeah, we are too weak.
Maybe turn the lever and then...
Okay.
Oh, maybe we like throw it back.
Not like in the twerking kind of way, but like down the
other pathway.
Like because, yeah, the other pathway.
Boom.
Oh, this is a lot faster.
Pushing is a lot faster than pulling.
Oh, but the door is shut.
Oh, there's a button here!
Yeah, yeah.
Hit that button.
your special job go queen let's go
okay oh i think we're gonna get stuff in there oh and then i
think we're gonna ride something to it and then we're gonna
land up here i hope it's human meat and candy yeah oh oh oh
it was empty that's why yum okay you got it yeah yeah yeah
pull you pull that
work see we can work together yeah she's been working out
i've been doing pilates yeah yeah she's been doing with her
weight weights she's up to 400 pounds now yeah body weight
body what how'd you know i'm a fake legend yeah all muscle
well have you seen those body building competition like male
and female that shoes and they look tree chickens okay no
you don't okay then you climb up and do the trapeze oh this
is gonna be epic okay what first try i got the camera grab
my grab my feet oh wait oh wait yeah i gotta don't worry
yeah oh oh it's okay she's blind and she's old yeah she's
getting closer but she We're irrelevant.
Yummy.
Candies.
Yay.
Oh.
All right.
Yeah, see, I told you.
She's blind and old.
It looks like four skin.
Thanks.
It's the extra skin.
If four skin is so good, where's the five skin?
Ask your mom.
She knows where it is.
Oh my god.
You're kidding.
We both tried to, we both so rude.
We both tried to shove each other up the lane.
It's like, no, it's my turn.
All right, you go first.
You go first.
All right.
All right, I'm a lady.
Here we go.
We're about two six.
All right, I need you to, all right.
Oh, I'll open this, open this.
Open the word.
Her arms are not long enough.
Her arms.
Oh, okay.
Maybe her arms are long enough.
Maybe.
I know, I know, I gotta choke him.
Oh, okay.
Get him a stool.
Yeah.
Come on.
Oh my god, he's like, he's like, he's like, get up, please.
I'm joking.
Give me your hat.
Come on, come on.
Oh, get in there, get in there.
See?
We saw the hole.
See, we're getting better.
We're improving.
We're improving our time.
I think we can make, I think we can make top 10 on the
speedrun boards.
And I think we leave.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
This music is so scary.
Oh,
no, oh, no.
We're all the way.
It's because we want to watch the cutscene.
We just want to watch the cutscene.
Oh, my.
Okay, I'm gonna pop you up.
I'm gonna pop you.
I'm up here.
All right.
Okay, okay.
Extendo.
She's not in the arms.
All right.
Slides!
I am watching.
What the f- Did you see that?
Did you see that?
What?
I need a referee.
Yeah, I saw it.
You fucked up the jump.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
Yeah, on my screen.
It was lag.
On my...
You can't jump on that chair.
You can't jump on the chair.
Yeah, just like how you could.
It made the other...
Don't keep her telling me to jump, guys.
Reporter.
In Minecraft.
I mean it is working I mean to be fair to be fair the last
two jumps is worked okay you go first I'm gonna copy you all
right watch this all right you can do that right there you
go there you go now the third jump yeah my dad inspired me
all right I had to put my Jordans on
survival the fittest we can always make gv6 okay oh it's a
crusher you want to see something she's getting mommy long
legs yeah she is hydraulic press oh this is so satisfying oh
she got a mammogram and then we can freeze dry her oh we can
put her in resin like resin yeah In our living room.
Turned her into an ashtray.
Yeah, it'll never rot, you know?
Yeah.
I have a little momento.
What's that?
Oh, should we check what's in here?
Oh, that's true.
I don't know, like, which one progresses.
Yeah, me neither.
I don't think there's anything here.
Empty.
Maybe this is, like, seems like a room where there's
something secret in it.
Maybe.
Maybe it's lore.
There's a lot of, like, stamps and stuff.
Maybe it's the UPS.
Oh, yeah.
A meal room.
Alright.
Wait, there's something to our...
Is there something to our left?
Yeah.
Door.
Oh?
Oh, they're like little...
Oh, it's like a little tailor room.
Maybe they got birds in those things.
The cages.
No, I think it's for like dresses.
Oh, I found a statue.
You found the pet of the...
No, these are like the little dresses.
Like the...
Oh, it's weird.
Like, where should...
she hides her yeah where she hides her gross at like no ass
okay she just died that's kind of too soon like come on have
some like social awareness okay um but i would never see
something out of pocket like that i do wish we saw that cut
scene again i know sex that we didn't oh hey hit that thing
oh yeah yo yo yo maybe we both hit it at the same time knock
knock who's there oh maybe throw that at it maybe oh i think
it's just candy though yeah but i'm strong watch this yeah
i'm watching oh you were so strong wait what we're so dumb
we just have to touch it
um hitting it is another form of touching Why are we so
violent?
Why are we so violent?
Yeah, boo.
Oh, I have to grab your hand.
Grab my hand.
I'm grabbing it.
Take it.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Grab it.
I'm.
Wait, are you not grabbing it?
Wait, I can't move.
Wait, I can't.
I can't.
Grab my hand.
I think we're by.
Wait, really?
Yeah, I think we're by.
You're levitating.
What is that?
I'm levitating.
Grab my hand.
Oh, no.
Daddy, don't feel so good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, I'm ready to grab my hand.
All right.
Grab.
Oh, there we go.
We did it.
You didn't even go in the mirror.
You did long.
Firmly grasp it.
Oh?
Wait, you didn't go through.
Wait, I didn't go through.
Wait, there's a lot of common here.
Wait, am I not real?
Am I just a voice in your head?
Oh, oh, never mind.
I'm real.
JK.
He has crisis.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just...
Sorry, I was just lagging.
I had, like, 500 ping.
It's your ping, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Amigo.
Of course.
You still owe me $50.
From that time I bought you that birthday present, it wasn't
cheap.
That was the best DVD I ever had.
Oh, hey.
Oh, there's a little...
Oh, yeah, we can eat him in the other little nightmares.
I think here, right?
Twilight's not with the power of friendship.
Come on.
Do you ever watch My Little Pony or are you, like,
actually...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, no, actually, what do you mean, normal?
Brofist?
It was, excuse me, it's Pegasisters?
No, Brofist, no, Brofist, you're thinking of a...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Brofist is like the, the, you know, like the symbol of it.
No, isn't it?
Hoof, hoof, what was it?
No, Brohoof.
Brohoof, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Brohoof.
Pony's don't have fish.
I was thinking of PewDiePie.
Where did you get PewDiePie from my little pony?
Brohoof, Brofist?
It's the same word.
Technically, oh, he went on the couch.
Ew, you want to sit, I'm gonna sit on that.
Oh yeah, sit on that.
Yeah, it's a perfect chair to sit on.
It's like a little trampoline.
Like a massage, you know?
Nice.
Alright, I'm gonna go now.
How, you stomped on him.
I think, oh, wait, maybe?
Who is your favorite pony?
Rainbow Dash.
You actually, I can see that.
I'm a Fluttershy fan.
I like her voice.
Her voice is just, oh, there it is.
I feel like you kind of sound like her.
No.
You gotta like that compliment?
But she has...
Her voice is, like, super raspy.
You get crunchy a little, yeah.
Oh.
Are we dumb?
No, we get...
Now she's up there.
We're gonna drop a bottle.
I should catch it.
Yeah.
Catch the bottle.
I don't think they're gonna knock it down.
What's the point?
Oh, we shoot it.
Can you shoot it?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there he is.
Ow!
He's so ungrateful.
They're in, like, a little game with it.
Oh.
Here?
Let's come at the fair.
Oh, oh, he got the ladder.
It's good at her.
What?
Do we have to...
From here?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Oh, there's a rat in here.
Do you see the rat?
Where is it?
Yeah, I see it.
She's right in front of me.
Yeah.
Oh, the what?
I was not looking at the glass one.
Was there another rat?
Yeah, there was another one.
I missed it.
I love rats.
They make good pets.
They're like really smart, but they don't live very long,
sadly.
Yeah, but the great thing about it is that they can make a
lot of babies.
That's true.
Really, really fast.
So you can have like the descendants.
What?
Wait, maybe?
I feel like we're supposed to go up here, but it's not.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I feel like we already pulled the thing as much as we
could.
Unless there's more.
But wait, there's more.
Okay, pull this.
Come pull this.
Oh!
Yeah.
There's the handle.
Oh, and then we jump over.
We're so smart.
Alright.
Look.
And then...
Parkour!
Do a flip!
Alright, and then...
Up we go.
Okay.
like a nice this music is nice i know it's not like we're
not playing for our lives now oh it's okay
reflex stay away cooties are coming i was sharing my
nutrients oh this motherfucker he ran down here she ran down
here Oh, the guy we're gonna eat?
Yeah, I'm hungry.
No, we've been, uh...
Oh.
I heard...
That was him.
I'm running up ahead.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, I was gonna say, that's...
I hope that wasn't bones crunching.
There's a light here.
Okay, we gotta grab.
Oh.
He's walking on it.
Oh, you can break this door here.
Yeah, I already broke it.
Oh, you're her.
Be kidding.
What's in there?
Um, oh, skibbity duck.
Oh, oh, it might be.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Is that a collectible, maybe?
Yeah, it is.
Oh, it is.
I was too distracted by this.
I was like a little bouncy monkey.
All right, we gotta go this way.
The mysterious, our food ran this way.
It's getting cold.
We gotta catch it.
before it gets too cold.
Yeah, five second roll.
Yeah, the five second roll.
Get over here.
Oh.
Are you?
Oh, hammer this.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Boom.
Oh, is that like an edge?
Oh, there you guys.
Grab him.
Get it.
Okay, now we eat him.
Get over here.
Let him cook.
I'm so hungry.
Also, we gotta go this way with the light.
Why is he so warm?
Oh, he's an orphan.
All his friends are dead.
Yeah, that's how being an orphan works.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
We's gonna do those fairs.
Fine.
See ya.
Us not having friends is a choice.
Exactly.
when I sleep until 4 p.m.
and don't speak to anyone except my parents, it's a choice.
Exactly.
I have so many people that reach out to me.
I definitely don't get excited when my phone buzzes, and it
turns out to be an Uber Eats notification every time.
Yeah, I mean...
Yeah.
That wasn't sad at all.
Oh, really?
Wait a little while?
Yeah, yeah, that wasn't...
Don't worry.
That was...
Yeah, yeah, you're not pathetic.
Don't worry.
That is the nicest thing you can always go lower.
Oh, what the fuck?
He came over here?
He's a fan.
He came with us.
Oh.
Where's the flashlight?
Oh, it's here.
Do you remember the second game with the flashlight?
Oh, yeah, I remember.
Okay, press R3.
Oh, no.
I'm putting a lot of faith in you.
Don't worry.
I'm dependable.
That's why my checks always come on time.
They do.
Okay.
I think we're looking for buttons to hit.
maybe oh wait wait there's a yeah sometimes they're a little
late but don't worry they always come on time sometimes
they're two to three months late eventually that yeah
eventually they arrive it's a doll shoot it you scared of
dolls yeah I hate I hate I hate dolls I'm scared of
mannequins I like I like dolls but I have to like sleep with
a life side like a child-sized doll in my room.
And I put it in my closet because I did not like waking up
to a life-sized doll looking at me every day.
But then the thing is when you're, when you put in a closet,
when you open the closet, you see it stare back at you.
So...
Oh no, and you forget it's there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's this way.
What is the flashlight even for?
I found a flashlight.
Oh, yeah.
Now we both have flashlights.
Where am I?
Oh.
Wait, oh.
Hit that button.
It was ping.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, ping diff.
Ping diff.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there's a thing up here.
Yeah, hit the pattern.
Oh, your arrow.
Oh, no, no, like you follow the pattern to the right.
I know for my...
Alright, this is your turn.
I think when the light...
Okay, I'm gonna hit that button and then you do the rest.
I got this.
Alright, everything depends on you.
No pressure.
Alright, and then you...
Boom.
Okay, okay.
I got this.
Boom.
I got him.
Alright, no pressure.
I see the person pattern now.
I see that now.
Let's move on as a society.
Let's move on.
Boom.
Let's go.
Oh my god, it works.
Actually, oh, nothing.
Nothing.
No, no, no, no, no, nothing.
I'm so proud of you.
Thanks, bro.
Here's my press.
Wait.
Is it actually?
Oh, I gotta help you.
Yeah, yeah, help me right here.
all right now that door is should open oh whoa i heard oh um
um um i'm a little concerned about i'm a little concerned oh
don't worry i have a flashlight okay so there was something
oh it's there was something that used to be in that in that
little Truly they're friendly.
It's in your closet.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
I forgot I moved it there.
You're right.
Uh-oh.
Whoa.
Woo-hoo.
Oh.
It's okay.
Get it out.
All right.
Get the violence out.
Oh, it's parkour.
We can do that.
It looks like a tap tree.
Yeah, this parkour.
Oh, it's not even...
That parkour is like baby parkour.
I've done mine crap.
Are you a cat person or a dog person?
I'm a dog person.
Oh, yeah.
I was a dog person and now I'm a cat.
I adopted two straight kittens and now I'm like, I get it.
Cats are cool.
I'm a fan of cats.
Wait, you have a dog?
What the cats are just a...
Yeah, I have a dog too.
He's a, what is it called?
A Labradoodle?
Yeah.
Oh, we are...
Okay, stay there.
Stay there.
get off get up we have it's too heavy am i big am i too big
no no no no no no no no no no no no of course not of course
not it's you know maybe maybe don't eat that that chicken
tonight but uh wait do we there you go yeah oh
which way should it turn that makes it easier
um oh i think a little bit more Look, it's catching up.
Oh, we're right here.
Yeah.
Now we can parkour.
See, we're not bad.
Yeah, see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't die.
Alright.
There you go.
And then we do that, and then...
And then don't do that.
Don't do that.
No, I'm just...
Oh, yeah, yeah, not to do.
Exactly.
I was like, I was like, don't worry.
Here are the things that you can fuck up on.
But don't worry.
You win.
I like the way for you.
This way.
Are you done?
No, no.
I was just showing everyone what not to do when they do
their run, you know?
They're visual.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
See, see, guys?
See, this is what you shouldn't do.
Guys, this is a little PSA for everybody.
Which I like to call it a Pasa.
See, there.
See, and that's how you actually do it.
Oh!
I feel like these guys are going to come out.
They're gay?
that too I mean there were two guys in there why were there
two guys in there two guys one display yeah oh oh oh no
they're playing prop hunt can't find me I'm underneath the
map oh watch out doesn't matter all about the cool alright
make the jump all right yeah just get it running all right
see you guys we were doing no we were just doing PSA you
know we're showing out what people not what not to do
remember right you gotta look your finger find your
trajectory and then make an exactly exactly now you do it
show how it's done I'm already on the other side here if you
fall I'll oh I I don't think you would have caught me.
I don't know.
Someone just said I scream like a rabid.
Can rabid scream?
Wait, how do they know that?
Like a rabid.
Oh.
No, I thought it was like a rabid, as in like a bunny.
Yeah, see?
It was just a...
Rabbids do scream, but it's like a more like a...
Wait, how do you know that?
Because rabbits are like animals that are like really
anxious all the time.
Oh, yeah.
I heard they could get a heart attack if they are too
anxious.
Like you're so stressed out you just get a oh, I mean that
works for humans too, but I have anxiety so like I might be
part rabbit Maybe that's why I sound like one.
Oh What the frick they took his legs, but oh shit.
They took his legs.
No, he's the guy from the the guy that likes chocolate Oh,
hey back in my day
Chocolate I hate chocolate up there oh my god that's why she
hates chocolate with them nice all right let's go up see
real puppies oh no oh that is a little too dark we go down i
don't know i'm scared oh brick oh it's getting oh i see that
horse oh i see that horse It's a collectible over here.
Oh, nice.
Nice and NFT for my collection.
All right, I'm releasing a token.
Don't worry, there won't be a rug pull.
Oh, yeah, didn't we talk about that?
We're going to do doki coin.
Oh, yeah.
No, it's real.
I have a doki coin.
And we'll put it, like, in the long terms of service at the
end that says you will be rug pulled.
No, no, you might not be rug pulled.
It's like the...
Oh, you might.
Yeah.
It's like the possibility.
Is that Peter Griffin?
Oh, my God.
It's the Peter Griffin.
Oh, my God, it's the pose.
is it wait there's something up here yeah oh it's up here is
it safe in there yeah it's very safe it's just a very long
tunnel this is like the start of ratatouille
oh oh wait oh there's a gun bomb machine full of heads oh
that's a popcorn machine full of maggots
It's like my movie theater.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, that's the prototype.
Oh.
Oh, God.
Did you play through chapter the new?
No, I didn't play it.
I never played any of the Poppy playtime, but I've seen
playthroughs of it.
I heard the new chapter was pretty ass, though.
They're honestly fun as long as you make fun of them a
little.
Okay, this guy's contained.
I do not want him to come out.
What did he?
do oh whoa he's a fighter oh he's a you remember that
portrait that we uh i told you we took him to the took her
to the farm downstate that's the one where the portrait was
taken down oh no is this the farm yeah this is the farm
downstate we shoot him shoot your brother do it that's the
only way oh so now head i'm gonna smash it oh yeah and then
we smash it it's the only way survival of the fittest boom
no poppy playtime is really like gosh if you're okay with
like hating the puzzles that when you actually play the game
it's fun yeah her like newest chapter was just chase
sequence after chase sequence after chase sequence every
game honestly in poppy really like the chase sequences when
they're not broken every time there's so broken yeah because
you get played on the launch too right so yeah so like yeah
i heard that like the reason why it's so bad the newest
chapter is because the the lead developer or the lead the
the main creator they changed the whole story and like i
don't know yeah i don't know much about the games besides
playing them, I don't really do the lore stuff.
So, like, I didn't notice anything, really, but apparently
the story, like, shifted a lot.
Oh.
Oh, there's a...
Wait, is that a button over there?
No.
Which I gotta pull this?
What do we do?
I'm seeing colors that don't exist.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna hang out here.
See, you are a bad guy.
You thought that was funny.
Yeah, it's a good dad joke.
Is that a button I can have?
Yeah, I was going to say, is that button?
Wait, there is...
That is going up.
Oh, wait, no, that is not.
Oh!
Oh, and then I do this.
I don't think I do that.
Maybe you go in.
Go in there.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, I throw...
I think you go in there.
No, I throw close.
No, I think you jump in there, actually.
How do I throw?
Space.
Okay, X.
Oh, there you go.
And then...
How'd you miss?
Hmm.
Can I miss?
There you go.
My eyes don't work like they used to.
That's okay, you're getting low on me.
There you go, good job.
Okay, we need to do one more because it has to be at the
red.
Can you do a 360?
Watch this.
You saw that?
Wait, that was sick.
Like, actually.
All right, see you later.
Okay, all right.
All right, that's fine.
Wait, I actually don't think I can't.
Wait, I actually don't think I can.
Oh, oh, oh.
I don't even need a present.
What the frick is this?
Don't worry.
Daddy's coming home.
I'm freaking running fast.
I'm speeding up.
Cheapy.
I smell cigarettes and alcohol.
I found a collectible.
Did you went up or down?
I actually don't even know anymore.
I went on the rooftop.
You definitely did not go where I went.
Because I...
Where'd you go?
I went up.
Oh.
Across the pipe?
What?
Oh, I thought I could climb that.
Sorry.
You hear me?
Uh, no.
Where are you?
I'm at the pipe.
Oh.
Are you at the pipe?
Yes and no.
Wait, where am I?
I don't know where you are.
Wait, where did I?
Where am I?
Okay, it's this way.
And then...
Oh, I need your help.
Oh, they just go up.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
off are you on a pipe right now yes all right I'm coming see
you you were not there what do you mean I'm right here look
see look see I'm right here what the Yeah.
There you go.
Oh, you're...
Someone wasn't patient.
I was trying to give you a hug.
This was like a hunter from Left 4 Dead.
Alright, don't worry.
Don't worry.
My hand's out.
Grab my hand.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'll pull you up.
I'm coming.
Don't worry.
You did it.
first try that all right then we pull this oh boom yeah i
was waiting i was up here i was like where is she oh you
were up there the whole time yeah i was up there the whole
time but i was up there too no i'm not waiting for you what
a thick way i'm watching your stream no i'm stuck i'm stuck
i am watching your freaking stream you dubious creature oh
oh i think there's someone behind that tent Foxy.
No way.
I think Foxy is here.
Alright.
Hoppies.
I hope it's Rock Sandwall.
Oh.
We need a key.
What is he doing?
I just listened to a radio.
I think he's about to open the door.
Maybe he's gonna open that hatch.
You see that hatch with the rope?
Wait.
Yeah, do you shoot it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I knew it.
You're the freaking farm.
yeah i was like what kind of food is that have you seen
those tick tocks what which one what kind of food is that no
no all right and you see that's why that's why i'm i still
my brain is not slush yet yet yeah dude hop on overwatch
that'll fix it there's still jelly there's a jelly
consistency but but we still have like one region yeah yeah
yeah yeah i still have one region of my Still active.
You got the frontal lobe.
Oh, look, it's the chair.
It's intervention.
Is this why you brought me here?
Yeah, I got it.
Chibi, you need to stop.
You need to stop.
We are so worried about you.
Oh.
Yeah, get up.
One thing.
Wait, is this...
I think...
Wait, what's over here?
And they're just like, you can't get up here.
Or you cannot...
Do I give you upies?
Yeah, upies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We need to revert to upies.
Yeah.
Why can't we just do upies all the time?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Push it, push it.
I think I can.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Oh, you gotta push.
It was push, not pull.
God, it's like, I know, I do that every time.
Like, why is...
Why do they always, like, pick at it?
Why can't it be one thing, you know?
Like, it's always push or it's always pull.
But then people gotta, like, be like, Nope, but what if...
We got...
It's messed up.
Then we gotta play around.
Oh, yeah, here.
Boom!
Puppies!
Oh, grab the key.
Grab the key.
I think that guy's gonna chase us.
I think so, too.
But wait, what key does that unlock, though?
The door next to the tent, I think.
Oh.
Meladia, I will show you.
Oh!
Oh, that's not...
See, I told you it was like, Chibi, we are so worried about
you.
They kind of look like me.
We're so worried.
Are these our Chibi?
Can you bring them there?
No, this is an intervention, Chibi.
Oh, oh.
We got your friends and family here to save you.
From what?
You have to stop.
Not in front of Granny, Chibi.
Follow me, Milady.
I feel like we're getting close to beating the game.
I think so, too.
Oh, boom.
Because I was like...
I cannot move.
Oh, I don't think it's here.
Because I saw...
Oh, maybe...
Oh, it's this way?
Wait.
Because when I looked up, I was like, how far...
How much do we have left?
The game was like...
It's like five or six hours long.
Maybe like six or seven.
Dude, look at these guys in creative mode.
It's Easter.
Don't worry.
On Sunday they will rise up.
You're having a good time.
Oh, I feel like somebody's gonna come out of that window.
This is like a room we're gonna get tickled.
Oh, this is where it's shut.
Oh, oh, oh.
Flash it with the white.
Oh, hey.
Oh, he wants a hug.
He's so friendly.
Yeah, I think we gotta flash him.
Yeah, flash him.
He'll run away.
That actually is my experience.
You flash him, and I got the wrench.
I got Daddy's special weapon.
Alright.
Okay, you don't flash it.
Wait, wait, you shoot him.
Remember?
You shoot him.
Remember the little mini-game from four months ago?
Oh, my God.
we were trained for this we were trained for this four
months ago i'm ready i'm stuck at the door i'm stuck i can't
i can't get him oh that's not good first no that oh okay
okay okay okay i'm ready i'm ready all right come here
you're dead and you smash his head oh what
No big grab, don't worry, don't worry now we don't.
We're lying.
It's been four months, guys, it's been four months.
The muscle memory's coming back.
The muscle memory's coming.
Okay, I'll wait here until you hit him.
I'm going to 360 him.
Okay.
And then...
Watch out for the buddy.
Oh, I got it.
There you go.
Watch out for this little boy.
Okay.
He's so bad, I got him.
I got him.
You know what I mean?
Like, oh, fake, fake.
You got bailed him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah.
just wearing a very long it's like a barbershop shop quartet
all right run away run away oh i missed run away keep
running keep running keep running keep running keep running
okay
okay okay that's just a practical we're warming up we're
warming up we're warming up just reminding you that my yeah
yeah yeah yeah at least minus autoing you have to actually
like get in position Your job is way harder than life.
Okay, okay, keep running, keep running.
I got it, I got it, I got it, don't worry.
He has to chase you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
See, look at that, look at that.
Look at that, look at that.
Okay, boom.
Okay, but he has to chase you and not me.
Okay, look.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's the lady.
Over here, my lady.
Bro!
What?
How did I get?
This is...
My eyes were like eight feet long.
It's like...
What the...
He was like, wait, this person is right next to me.
Why am I chasing?
Yeah, I don't want to walk over there.
We're getting better.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're learning.
360.
All right, I'm in that corner.
There's no way.
All right, there you go.
I'm hiding in the corner.
There's no way it sees me.
Yeah, there we go.
The next one's over here, careful.
Yeah, don't worry.
I'm in the shadows.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
See?
I'm like Batman.
Okay, winder, winder.
Alright.
Okay, I'll bait it over here.
I'm in the corner.
She's a cop?
Where is it?
It's so blurry.
I can't see her.
I'll get it.
Alright, we did it.
That was the last one, too.
That's right.
Okay, we just enjoyed that mini-game so much.
It was like, it was like daddy-daughter bonding time.
Yeah, exactly.
So we wanted to do it again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wanted to win a little more tickets.
Yeah, we gotta get the spider range.
Yeah, yeah.
We gotta get the switch, too.
Oh my god, look, it's you!
It's a chicken.
I don't think that's a chicken.
No, it looks like a chicken.
Oh, it's a rat mouse trap.
Oh.
Oh, it's a rat.
Yeah, it's a rat.
So it's you.
Why does everyone say that?
Is it because I have scoliosis or you ableist?
Oh my God, I'm, I'm Google Dockey.
She didn't deny it, boys clip it.
I, we gotta take her down.
I'm just- Oh my God.
What the frick are these things?
They're all head like me.
Wait, what is that?
Oh wait, they are just all heads.
Or I can't tell what they are.
I think they're literally just heads.
I can't even read my chat right now.
What is your chat talk like?
Are they like, wow, good job, Doki.
I love this game.
My chat is just hysterical at all times.
I can't even interact with them.
Wait, what did they say?
I don't even know.
They're talking about crumbs stored in your butt.
What?
Wait, it's bad.
Wait, that is you.
Look, look.
It's literally you.
And they have scoliosis, too.
Look at that.
Wait, here.
I gotta go do something.
There's Chibi 6.
There's Chibi 7.
TV 8 TV 9 TV I live yeah oh disgusting that's you I shower
yesterday I'm not disgusting all right oh we gotta take the
little zip line oh yeah it's like oh my this is our family
reunion this is so awesome dude i missed oh i have i can't
even i have to wait for you it's a it's a long climb oh no
oh wait oh nice yeah the cheebies have escaped the basement
god they didn't want to wait anymore yeah
look i got it yeah oh no oh we were at the other yeah we're
at the other side we did it we did it It's a speedrun tech.
No, no, it's a speedrun tech.
We did a frame skip, you know?
That's what we did.
Saw that?
You never know it was at the end of that zip line.
Yeah, that was my tech.
I invented that tech.
You look my, if you, if you Googled speedrun techs for
Dillow Nightmares 3, you'll see it right there.
Oh, dude, it's meat spin.
Oh, shoot.
Maybe shoot them.
Don't shoot them.
Don't.
He slapped his butt and he slapped me.
Okay.
Where do we do it then?
I'm gonna shoot them.
Right, the focus.
Why?
Okay, I can't shoot them.
I don't really like that.
Maybe, oh, maybe we climb up here.
No?
Huh.
Oh, wait, we're here, here.
Yeah?
Okay.
I need help.
Oh, good.
Gotcha.
Wait, where do we push this?
I actually have no idea where to put this.
Up here to put?
Oh.
Where do...
Is it?
I don't know.
Oh, maybe...
Oh, is there an entrance over?
Oh, there is.
Wait, is there?
Where do we can go?
Yeah.
No, that's just a plate.
Oh, wait.
Why?
oh oh it was just bugged up yeah we were just so tired um oh
there you go okay and then what's he gonna do his apples oh
he's so hungry he's distracted we can walk so hungry he's so
hungry oh my god wait he was just like you i am actually
really hungry Okay, let's go up Vamos puta I'm sorry, please
don't say I'm great.
Okay Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Oh, oh, oh, oh I was a little behind
I gotta distract it.
Yeah, I was just like, whoa, it's pinata.
I want to join me.
Do you get it?
The joke is that they're hitting a pinata of meat.
I think she got it guys.
I got that one I'll distract him Oh he wants you Oh what do
we do?
Wait wait wait wait wait I wasn't ready Oh my god I wasn't
ready for that I wasn't ready for that That's okay okay Okay
Alright now I'll make sure he goes after me I missed He did
go after you though He didn't He did it He was successful
It's okay it's okay you got like anxiety you know you got
like performance anxiety happens to everybody it happens to
everybody all right i'm gonna make sure he chases me come on
oh no oh no i'm so oblivious oh no no okay the um it baited
the other late and the other lady came over okay so i think
what we do is we make him run a little bit forward and then
you shoot him Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because he's like super close to the other girl.
Okay, like we maybe like bring him over here and shoot him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, bring him over.
Okay, okay, I'll bait him.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, shoot him, shoot him, shoot him.
Okay, nice.
All right, and then make sure he still chases you.
He hates me.
He freaking hates me.
Okay, he hates me.
Okay, I got it, I got it.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, and now this one?
All right, this one's super fast.
Okay, I'll bait it.
Come on, friend.
All right, nice.
We want walkies, walkies.
Come on.
We want walkies.
That's right.
Woo, walkies!
Good job.
All right, nice.
Look, they're hitting that thing.
Uppies.
It's your turn for upies.
Yippee!
Oh, hey.
Oh, my gosh.
We get the switch, too.
We get the pickup tickets.
Pick up.
Oh, my gosh.
I think that's 100,000 tickets.
Right here.
I'm not letting go.
This is the best day.
Oh.
It was the best day, man.
We had, like, 99,999.
I'm, oh, can we go in here?
I don't think so.
Oh, wait, it's like a dunking.
Yeah, yeah, go dunk him.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Oh, he's trying to get out.
Don't worry.
Oh, we're drowning him!
No, no, no, no, don't worry, don't worry.
He can breathe underwater.
Don't worry.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's half fish.
See?
See, stop moving because he's just breathing underwater and
sleeping now.
Oh, he got his, like, money and power.
yeah yeah when when we saw movement he was just trying to
find uh try to find his like melatonin he was celebrating
yeah i love i love the water yeah we were helping him get
into the water i left the skid mark on that roof i gotta
pull where do we push or pull this are you pushing or
pulling are you okay is i was pulling you were yeah yeah
yeah Oh, this looks like a chase Okay Yeah, I think Yeah, I
think, I think It does look like a chase Secret I smelt it I
don't know, we can Can we run past all of these?
Yeah, we do, we do, we run, we run We run, we run, we run We
do not run, oh, oh, we crouch We crouch Okay
Oh my god.
My child is like sleeping with the fishes.
Yeah, he was.
He was taking a nap.
Okay, now we'll just be very, very quiet.
They're really hungover, so they don't want any loud noises.
They look hungover right now.
That must have been a sick-ass party.
Yeah, they got lit.
Alright.
Oh my god, look at the...
little ride oh they're having so much fun yeah they're
having so much boys in creative mode look at them though
that does look like awesome fun we need to go there all
right
i might have started running at the end that scared the crap
out of me i did not realize it triggers it when i started
running wait oh there's your stool oh Wait, we push, we
push.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a little doggie door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's perfect size for us.
Oh, wait, there's a...
Crank it.
Crank it real good.
Crank it, soldier!
Yeah.
Oh, I gotta hold it.
Oh!
Wait, do I go downstairs?
Yeah, go down there.
Are you good?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just... It's like a...
It's like a two-meter drop.
Oh!
Wait, do you keep cranking it?
Keep cranking it.
I'm cranking that soldier boy?
Yeah, crank that soldier boy.
Did I do anything?
No, no, keep cranking it.
It's fully cranked.
Yeah, keep holding it.
Crunk.
Okay.
Oh.
Um.
Keep cranking it?
Oh, wait, wait, let go?
Okay.
What the fuck?
What is that area?
Check him.
out?
There's like nothing on this side.
Oh, you scared the freaking crap out of me.
What the fuck?
I'll crank it.
Okay.
Wait, I can like change it.
Maybe like in the middle?
I'm looking around.
I'm cranking it, but I don't know where exactly to leave it
at.
I see the light bulb in me.
Now watch me.
You want to watch me?
Hi, bye.
I'm cranking it?
I don't know what that does.
Maybe, like, we have to keep it at specific marking?
Because, like, we can have a specific area.
Oh!
Oh, I'm such a genius.
Oh, so I wasn't supposed to be there.
No, it's just I'm better.
It's...
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Uh-hmm.
Yeah?
You're what?
Where's a balloon over?
Wait, what?
There is it.
There is...
What is that for, then?
Like, the little crink?
I can't get up!
Oh, I can't get up.
Maybe it's after?
Maybe, yeah.
Oh, maybe it'll light up.
I think that powers that up.
I think that's what it does.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's that balloon, he shoot?
balloon oh wait shoot that balloon yeah oh it's a trinket
yeah it's a collectible all right now we can crank that
soldier boy
all right chibi yes crank that soldier boy are you cranking
it no no i'm giving you the honor oh i i gotta go up then i
was still at the lightning oh yeah come come
Don't worry, I'll sit on the chair.
I'll watch you.
It's like a recital.
Alright, Chibi.
Crank that soldier, boy.
Yay!
Are you?
Oh, I think I have to put it in the...
You know that section?
Because you can hold it.
That line where the song starts playing.
You're almost there?
I need one more.
One more crank.
Oh!
I think I gotta keep it running I go have fun in the circus
Yeah!
Go for them I think I go on to their side Yeah Have fun Oh
Nothing But this song is good though It's not here
Maybe go backwards?
Yeah I was gonna think All right, just keep
I am moderately cranking that soja boy Wait, can we even go
back?
Um Um Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll crank it I'm gonna
go check out one time All right
Okay, I'm looking around.
Yeah?
Okay.
Maybe it's like one of the other ones.
Yeah, maybe they want a different song.
Yeah, I was gonna sit.
See if there's like other...
She's like making gargoyle noise.
It's almost having a seizure right now.
Help him.
I'm going to look at the tunnels more.
Maybe to the left side.
You go left on the tunnels.
Maybe shoot the light.
Oh, okay.
Like on the machine or the weapon put in?
Yeah, the machine.
There's a light there.
Oh, now that is.
I know.
I feel like a game journalist.
I'm so confused.
All right, your turn.
Okay, I'm going back.
all right don't worry if our two brains combined maybe we'll
have maybe three brains on me no that's asking a bit too
much okay that's not it all right keep cranking it okay i
just got there i'm going all right keep cranking it all
right i'm cranking it
all right it's on your song All right, all right, my song's
on.
Hey.
Okay, wait.
Do you think?
I don't think so.
No.
Yeah, I think we're stuck in there.
Preston.
Why are we so dumb?
No, no, no.
We're not dumb.
It's the puzzle.
The puzzle is poor.
poorly made.
It's not us.
Are you sure there was nothing to shoot at?
Yeah, I've been pressing F and it doesn't lock on anything.
here keep pushing i'll try to yeah all right i'm gonna do it
shoot anything just keep just spam it i gotta wait for him
like if he puts it in the air like he just don't care and
then i can shoot something all right yeah nothing
bump bump i'll i'll try and shoot something in the tunnel
Yeah, I think it's something inside that room.
Which room?
The one you're in.
Yeah, I think so.
I didn't know that's what I'm saying.
I think there's something in here.
Oh, someone said jump to the lamp.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't try shooting the lamp, but he didn't want to.
Let's try again.
Let's jump.
Someone had jumped there.
Oh, jump there?
Yeah.
Oh, maybe look up here?
Yeah, yeah, you go up there, and then you jump towards it
and see if you can grab it.
Oh.
You are so smart.
Oh, my God, we're so smart.
We figure that out ourselves.
Mods cut out the part where we're going to chat.
No, I would never.
We don't even know how to read.
Exactly.
How could I re-chat if I don't even know how to...
Ah!
all right chibi seven six seven all right get up it's your
time get out of the basement is your chair oh my god it is
yeah all right it's this way oh oh it's a supply now we can
actually do it rematch you see you weren't able to do the
dokey tech the dokey skip that's okay yeah it's i'll never
Why is it called the dokey skip?
Not the cheeby dokey skip.
I know.
Don't worry, I'll catch you.
Okay.
All right, jump.
I'm going to catch you.
Okay.
Oh, you caught me thinking.
Oh, see, look at that.
I got you that.
I pushed that all the way here.
You're so strong.
I know.
Well, I think we need to push.
We got to push it back.
Well, not this way, apparently.
Well, I feel like we got...
Oh, we grab his legs.
Little feets.
Little feetsies.
I'm going to sniff while I do it.
Oh, he has his bootstrap.
Oh.
Oh, is it humorous?
It looks...
I think it's a rotten cake.
I think that might be cake.
Yeah, yeah.
I think that's cranberry sauce.
It could be a red velvet cake.
Yeah, with some fog in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's okay.
We all suck sometimes.
Come on.
The performance is...
toilet.
It's performance.
It's performance anxiety guy.
Oh, I'm having a moment.
I'm having a moment.
Do not talk to the skibby-d guy.
Do not talk to him.
Oh, I'm here.
Wait, what's...
Do not talk to him.
He's trying to prevent piracy.
I know.
Alright, shoot a balloon.
The walk.
Alright, I guess we don't shoot the balloon.
I got it.
Oh.
Oh, that happened off screen, which means she's still alive.
Yeah, I'm alive.
You didn't see the body.
I didn't see the body, guys.
It's just a cutscene.
So, when you see a hand coming out, that might look like
it'll grab you.
It's going to grab you.
Do I dab it up?
All right, so see that?
You're like, oh, he's definitely...
Yeah, he's like, you're like, it doesn't look dangerous.
It's apparently dangerous.
I know, it's so hard to tell with these games.
exclude, you know?
Where's my, where's my yellow paint?
Yeah, where's my yellow paint?
There should have been yellow paint on the hand, so I would
know that, oh wait, balloon.
Yeah, like yellow nail polish.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is for you.
Yeah.
You ding.
Oh, I thought how you climbed it.
Oh.
Open the door.
What?
I think I smash it.
Oh, did I smash it?
Maybe.
Smash!
Daddy's angry.
We keep having to buy new doors.
What the fuck am I going to do with all these forks?
Oh, right here.
Right here.
Come.
Oh.
Hello.
Oh, we're invading his private time.
I'm going to shoot him in the butt.
He's distracted.
He doesn't know.
Oh, yeah.
He's too busy, jorky.
it.
Oh, look at Freddy Fazbear.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I think.
I think you need to be violent again.
Oh, violence doesn't solve everything.
Do you need to have buckies?
No.
Oh, that's just an apple.
Now's not the time.
To keep this off.
Weird.
Oh.
Oh, we have to have get him to hit the thing here.
Oh, he's got a blindfold on.
Okay, don't worry.
You bait him.
I'll be, I'll watch.
Okay, okay.
You were not beating the cuck out.
No, I'm like, no, I'm trying to scout it, scout it, you
know?
I'm making sure.
Careful.
All right, see, look at that.
I'm just making sure I'm scouting out, you know, scouting
our backs.
Covering our backs.
Oh!
Did we win?
Oh, wait, wait.
You gotta grab, we gotta get the tickets.
You want your Switch 2, Chibi?
We gotta get the tickets.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, just five more, five more?
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You shot a girl.
You shot a little girl.
I am a feminist.
No.
Don't shoot air.
If you fuck up, you know what's gonna happen.
No, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Ow!
what's gonna happen daddy wants her switch too all right all
right nice
that was fun i like how i get all the fun mini games and you
just get i just go like dokey smash
dokey fall
oh we gotta oh no we don't gotta beat this yeah we already
did it we already did it yeah yeah we got a prize we got
achievement oh malady Can we even grip that?
Now I'm concerned.
I think I can, I think I can.
Oh yeah, yeah, I grip it.
You can, you can, you can.
Okay.
Do not embarrass yourself.
Alright.
Okay.
Cool.
See where it came from.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The motivation ignited something in me.
I don't want to get clipped.
Not again.
I like how you...
I like...
You said motivation.
Ew, are these teeth?
Ow.
Oh, they're like the toy teeth.
You know, the ghost says that.
We're whining at it.
Did he was...
I was going to say, did he give us flashlights?
I feel like I never use it.
Until now.
Alright, up these.
Wait.
Oh, we got to do a...
We got to do a jump.
Parkour.
Like parkour.
Oh, nice.
Good job.
We should do it the same time.
Like, synchronized.
Alright, yeah, yeah.
Do a countdown.
on go okay three two one go oh that was so clip it guys clip
it clip it we're so in sync there's a collectible over there
i gotta get it oh frank oh frank i'm definitely waiting for
you i'm i'm right i'm right next to you right now don't
worry i'm getting a collectible i'll be there in a second
your smoke break right now don't worry take as much time as
you want i'm just taking a little smoke break oh wait you
look sick you've got aura yeah i can't oh be free
all right don't worry you'll make it it's slow as hell this
is nice oh it's nice it's like a little oh it's like a
little train ride yeah do you know it's a christmas train
rides We're celebrating all the holidays.
You know, it's your birthday, it's Christmas, like,
Disneyland, Christmas.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, get all the way in one day.
All the time that the judge told me to do.
Just get out one day.
Yeah.
Yay.
Put your hands in the air.
It looks like you're going faster.
That's probably it.
Look at that.
Happy Halloween.
Dude, I want to go on a roller coaster.
Have you ever been on one?
Yeah, I love roller coasters.
I'm a pussy when it comes to roller coasters.
I just closed my eyes.
Yeah, I cannot.
It's because a lot of them have animatronics, too, for
roller coasters.
Also because I'm afraid of heights as well.
So I feel like, you know how there's freak accidents for
roller coasters.
And then you're like, you don't know.
Maybe today's the day.
Today's, you're going to be a statistic.
Today's the day.
will become these statistics i i can't see it on my glasses
so i literally have to like ride roller coasters like i'm an
anime protagonist with a finger between my glasses like you
know like they're shining yeah i like to ride them like that
and then like for a lot of roller coasters also have like
animatronics so i know in my head i'm like what if what if
that today's the day where they're gonna come alive and grab
me you know exactly yes no that's fair enough that's why i
don't do haunted yeah i don't i don't do like i don't do
like anything with animatronics i don't fuck with that i
Can't even do it.
Like, it's a small world.
Freaks me out, too.
Do you like Five Nights at Freddy's?
I actually accidentally got a world record playing Five
Nights at Freddy's.
But then I...
I got on the top, like, the...
I got, like, an accidental speedrun record on it.
On my first try.
But then, but then, you know how, like, I don't know if you
remember FNAF 1, but, like, the UI is, like, very poorly
coded.
And it's supposed to be, like, Continue or new game, but
even if you've never booted the game up, it'll still be like
you can still click on continue So because I click continue
Um, they couldn't count my time because like for the
official speed run you have to click new game like glitched
it No, I didn't glitch it's more so like What's on your
list?
I think that those are my are you on the naughty list.
Oh, yeah, you found out you're adopted?
Yeah, I'm sorry you're a clone and my dad this whole time
I'm sorry, you were actually cloned in the basement.
I'm a homunculus.
You're literally, um...
Where is it called?
When people...
You're...
You're a clone baby?
Oh, while looking at yourself in the mirror?
Damn.
Listen.
There's a word for it.
Like the...
The jar babies.
What are they called?
Test you, baby.
You're a test you, baby.
Really?
Yeah.
I said you never got some.
No, no.
I mean, the first one, yes.
But then, you know, after that.
Then you just, like, copied my DNA.
Yeah, the copy and paste.
Control C, control V.
It's just easier.
I got you something.
Yeah?
Oh, world's greatest dad.
Oh.
Happy Father's Day.
I'm so glad you like it.
Oh, I can't.
No, I was trying to display it, you know?
I was trying to hold, you know, when you were...
look out to look out in the sky and just be like wow my
child gave me this why are you hiding it no no i'm very
proud of it i'm very very proud of what you did i just want
to keep it safe you know i don't want to lose it oh that was
that was different oh yeah that was different that was not
the one you gave me right yeah there's a copy there's my
personal copy oh yeah you control c control v that one wow
you're so you're so so tech savvy i don't know right you'll
see me use the powerpoint oh my god can you use this you'll
see all these transitions i put on my powerpoint
presentation oh my god i love the one that like flips around
oh yeah yeah and then like the the slide transitions too and
then like each slide has like the title bouncing around oh
shit that's a rat just gonna ignore that and keep going
don't dead inside don't
dead open inside
what about shyness into your eyes oh yeah oh do you that the
optometrist oh yeah yeah yeah i'm trying to make sure that
try to make sure your eyes work wait do i that's right
puppies yeah i feel like i've still been alive in that no
i'm pretty sure it's dead Okay.
Don't worry.
See?
You can hold his hand right here.
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your first time holding someone else's hand.
That's not mine.
Oh, he's so awesome.
Don't worry.
I'll take a photo.
So, am I pregnant now?
Yeah, you didn't.
I forgot to tell you the word protection.
It's your present!
Oh!
There it is.
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
I'm so glad you left.
I
That's what you do to beautiful things.
You break it, Gibi.
Lesson number one.
Now you do sound like my daddy.
What the fuck?
I can't help believe I just had one.
I made that.
Like I crafted it in pottery class.
And then you can make it again.
And then you can break it again.
It's been a lot since something scary has happened.
I know, right?
like a casual walk in the park like we're actually going
we're actually at disneyland right now just enjoying the
rides yeah this is great like mickey mouse is here oh wait
where where where we got oh there's no it's uh walt disney
no because walt disney we got oh look he's giving you a hug
walt disney and little disney yeah disney jr dsney jr yeah
we took him out of the
Come inside, it's fun inside.
We got a secret mouse control.
M-I-C-K-E-Y-L-H-O-U-S-E.
Mickey Mouse.
Donald Duck.
Okay, I think we're supposed to crouch.
I think we're supposed to be...
I think we were supposed to be stealth mode.
Yeah, you're so intelligent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Walt Disney needs his nappy time.
He bites.
You know?
Yeah.
That's why he's been cryogenically frozen for so long.
You know, we're slowly adapting him.
They're slowly introducing him to Netflix.
Ricky, please!
I got my goofs caught in the mosquito.
I know my impression is really good.
M-I-C-K-E-Y-M-O-U-S-E.
we are seeing two different generations of mickey mask up it
was what are you are you are you push or pull are you
pushing are you i'm pulling i'm pulling i'm pulling okay i'm
pushing okay i'm pushing okay i'm pushing now i'm okay um
take her take her i'm gonna dodge him that dodged him i'm
gonna stand still the ultimate strategy hot dog hot dog hot
digity dog
was cremated that's what they want you to think but i've
seen it people who like take the ashes of their grandma and
throw them on mickey mouse rides like what the frick what
people take their ashes of their loved ones in the rides oh
my it's a small of all the places actually yeah they all
places like please do not take your dead grandma don't don't
don't do not do not do not Unplug the TV?
Can we?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think so either.
Yeah, I can't grip anything.
Can I grip the TV?
No?
Okay, trust me, pull it.
This time it'll work.
Okay, okay.
Is it working?
We gotta go.
Get the other one!
He's releasing the hell.
Oh, no.
It's Mr. Brando.
Wait, did you get us?
Did he?
My screen's black.
Oh, wait, wait.
It's... Oh, no, no.
Okay, never mind.
All right, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
We figured it out.
We just gotta keep... We just gotta keep gripping.
We got...
Grip it.
We gotta grip it.
All right.
It's rewind time.
all right here we go all right start gripping me to grab his
feet which he doesn't even have feet what do you mean he
does the guy doesn't oh the sleeping guy oh we gotta get uh
gripping gripping gripping gripping oh no oh no run run run
run run run run run run run run run run run run oh
We're so dumb.
Like, another room.
What do we do?
Oh, no.
We need, we, guys, this cutscene's so good, don't we?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I love seeing him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like meeting Walt Disney again, you know?
I waited so long this meeting, great live.
It's like they were back in the day.
It's okay.
Guys, I love this cutscene.
I love it so much that I won't watch it again.
Okay.
Got it?
All right.
the lid all right gripping we're gripping all right pull the
other one pull the other i'm gripping i'm gripping it i'm
gripping it gripping it okay okay okay what are we after
this i didn't really process it jump over here jump this
jump this jump here jump here jump here i was wrong i was
you were so wrong oh my god there's a bite there was
somebody can't get you i didn't go in the cardboard box and
hide there was one okay okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i saw
a button though Did you see that button over there?
I didn't.
Where was it?
Okay, wait, I think it was a button, but I'm not sure.
Okay.
Maybe, like, they gave us, like, five seconds.
They literally gave us, like, five seconds to process
everything.
This is actually what it's like to play Poppy Playtime in
the new chapter.
It gives you five seconds to figure out.
It's the worst.
All right, here we go.
Okay.
Hello.
All right, grip.
Grip it.
Grip it real good.
oh my god all right keep gripping keep gripping okay okay
you see that button to our left you see that button right
here it's not a button i can't tell that's not a button
that's not a button okay uh now we do the box that now yeah
i told you it was circle every circle is a circle is button
and you see a circle you push the button okay now we do your
okay Just now we do your box idea sorry my it was my idea,
right the box now.
We do my box idea You had the button idea.
I had the box idea Yeah, let's go.
Yeah.
Yeah Oh Gripping Gripping All right Gripping it real good
All right gripping again gripping again.
All right Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Box box.
We're my where am i i got stuck i was like i was in the dark
it was in the i blimmed it in with the shadows i couldn't
find myself i think your ping was high you were yeah yeah i
was rubber banding i was in the box and it like teleported
me outside of the box guys yeah yeah yeah all right here we
go
guys guys this is this is only our second attempt yeah and
when i post this on youtube it definitely yeah yeah yeah
remember to cut every everything will be first try it'll be
like wow we're so good and then the comments are like wow
she's really good at this she's so good this is faster than
most people like yeah i did box time crouch in the box okay
he has no more he doesn't know oh he's so fucking stupid
look at him i'm gonna shoot him i'm gonna shoot them no
don't don't do it don't do it don't do it don't do it don't
do it don't do it don't do okay it's one of those buttons
you can't hit yeah yeah it's one of those like see it's one
of those buttons you can't hit see it's not my fault but it
is a button it is a button look it's a It's meant to be
pushed.
Oh, he's hungry.
We go back.
Oh, oh my God, he saw you.
He saw you.
No, please don't make us.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're past that stage.
We're past.
Watch this with style.
Oh.
Okay.
Go back, go back, go back, go back, go back, go back, go
back, go back, go back.
I can't wait to hit that button.
What?
There's no way he knows.
Oh.
What's he gonna do?
Oh, he's like a doctor.
He's saving his life.
Yeah.
He's doing surgery right now.
It's like a grape.
Yeah.
Oh.
Really really big yet.
Oh, oh, it's a really really big grape.
It's like ours.
Yeah
He's like my food my food.
Oh, he doesn't see us.
Don't worry Okay, we're in the shadows we blend right.
Okay, so when he eats we we go under the table Because he's
like covering it up.
Oh, he's so greedy.
Look at him.
His greed knows no bounds my god he eats so fast look at him
he's like i'm yum yum yeah he's just okay okay okay no no no
no we wait for him to wait i think oh wait okay go now two
later don't be much love all right don't worry i got this i
got okay okay i was just yeah next rotation you know I just
gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure.
Let her cook.
Yeah, let me cook.
I love how he slams his little cup.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, are we safe here?
Surely.
Okay, yeah, surely, right?
Hide, hide, hide.
I'm stuck on the top!
And now we go that way.
Oh, now we go, yeah, yeah, now we go the other way.
Okay, I'm sprinting.
I'm sprinting too.
The door the door It's not the door.
It's not the door.
Oh, maybe like Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no!
Maybe we hit the button now.
Oh, maybe.
Okay, maybe there's an item there that we missed.
I'll go across.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yee-yee-yee-yee.
No, no, I can't, we can...
Oh, we...
Yeah, hide there, hide there.
I'll hide here.
Okay, okay.
All right, he's cutting.
He's standing in the mat, meat.
There must have been an item, maybe in that third room that
we missed.
Look on the table!
There's a lever!
Wait, what?
The triangle lever!
Oh, yeah!
Okay, wait, but how do we get up there, though?
Wait, how do we get up there?
I don't know.
Alright, alright, don't worry.
You go...
Okay.
Oh, you already go...
Oh, there you are.
I'm right behind you.
Wait, can we up-ease that?
Maybe we can up-ease that.
Yeah, I'll give you up-ease.
You grab it and then...
He's almost done with the meat.
Okay, okay, okay.
Are you ready?
Yeah, and then we all used to get the level.
Okay.
I'll wait for you.
And then...
Oh, we can just jump in.
Okay, can you do that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm gonna just go run.
Alright.
Now wait here, wait here, wait here, go here, go here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that boy scares me!
I think I was crouching, motherfucker, you're disgusting
creature.
I'm putting it in.
Screw you.
Checkpoint me give that that was a checkpoint right there.
Come on.
Is that the dokey skip?
Is that I don't I don't think that was the dokey skip I
think you should get the lover.
You're a better parkour.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
You're right Okay, I'll give you a piece this time
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right lag lag lag lag lag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch this See?
I stopped lagging.
Sorry, I had, like, 800 ping.
No, it's okay.
Yeah, yeah, you know, it happens sometimes, you know?
Alright.
He's watching.
He's cutting his meat.
That's called circumcision.
I think...
I think it's far gone.
I'm pretty sure he doesn't have anything anymore.
Alright.
He's looking right.
He's so stupid.
Oopid?
What is he?
Oopid or something?
Oh.
Oh, he went back.
Oh, hey, go, go, go, go, go.
You're so back.
We're so back.
Alright.
Can we go now?
Or...
I mean, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We missed it.
We gotta go when he's going.
Clank, clank, clank, clank, clank.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'll go the clink, clink, clink, right after.
And he grabs this, he grabs another knife.
And there we go.
Clink, clink, clink, clink, clink, clink, clink, clink,
clink.
Clink, clink, clink, I'm so hungry.
Starve.
Okay, you give up piece here.
I'll give you a piece on the table, okay?
Okay.
No, I don't need up piece, remember?
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, I can't, I can't, I can't, oh, I can't, I can't,
I can't, I can't, I can't go.
Why didn't you go first?
Go, go, go, go.
I'll meet you there, queen.
I fucked up.
We gotta do this again.
We gotta.
I'm back here.
I'm waiting.
I picked up my hammer.
That's okay.
I picked up.
Oh, no.
I think he's gonna grab me.
No, you live.
I was like, that's a hammer?
I'll show you a real hammer.
I'm just going.
Alright.
I just wanted to show her what a real hammer looks like.
I'm so impressed.
Yeah.
This guy looks like he would host a game show.
He does.
He looks like he'll host a game show.
jeopardy all right here we go and then it's gonna give him
his little meat all right i think you should do the parkour
i think because like you fit the hole better you know you
get the hole first and then i'll meet you at the other side
oh but i'm so bad i gotta believe in yourself oh frick oh
it's okay it's okay he's gonna be like and then
Go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go
Who moved up the pavement there?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was a pothole there, guys.
You didn't see it, but there was a pothole.
We got to call it district to fix this pothole.
Think of the kids.
All right.
You're so smart to hide here.
Okay, okay, okay, wait until he eats that.
All right, I'll go behind you.
Okay, we got crouched, though.
We got crouched.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, look, your dinner.
All right, let's go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I can't believe we did this.
We're so freaking good.
Okay, I'm not even...
I'm still crouching.
I don't care.
I'm sick.
Oh, it's saved.
I don't care.
It freaking auto saved.
Crank that soldier boy.
Crank that soldier boy, shouldn't you?
Crank it.
All right, nice.
Dodge.
Oh What happened?
I did not open it far enough and it shut I shut it Oh, they
got the crank the crank Oh my god, they're cranky I was
gonna be it didn't shut in front of you Did it actually It
did It's like no enter
Keep cranking, keep cranking Don't worry, you got this, you
got this You got it I did it, I did it, I did it That was so
freaking scary.
At least he's gone now.
Chow's like, Doki, wait for her.
I was like, one Doki has to live.
To continue the bloodline.
We got to continue the Doki line.
Yeah, I feel like you probably have better genetics than me.
You're really good at shooters.
So, you got something.
Alright, nice.
Granny gumjobs.
Sorry, the dentures.
Where are we heading?
Oh.
Alright, that perception.
Boom.
First try, look at that.
Speed run.
Boom.
Speed run, tech.
Wait, where are we?
Oh, there we are.
Speed run.
I think we're gonna get...
In the speed run, you have to wait.
Yow!
Oh, okay.
I don't...
Speedrun
I can't tell where it is!
Where is it?
I can't see it!
Okay, okay, I think it's- oh wait, do we have to pull this
lever?
Wait, was there no- was- no, there's no- Oh my god, there
was- That thing.
I gotta trust me.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we gotta wait.
We gotta wait.
It was, it was just in the background.
I, I, um, um, careful, careful.
What happened?
What happened to, you gotta trust me.
Careful, SpongeBob.
For some reason, I'm starting to lose my trust in you.
I were gonna let it go.
Like, I was gonna let it go.
frozen you gotta like get it like a little bit closer a
little bit closer i don't worry i can i can be at the edge
okay okay oh my god oh my god okay okay okay okay okay i
swear to god if i see another lever on my side oh guess what
there's a lever on my side i'm so ready i trust you fully
air fryer yes i'm edging it i'm edging oh i fell okay i
edged it
i don't need you i don't need you i'm gonna make the job i
need you i need you i need you my core here we go all right
this way
anyway i was there on day zero when that happened yeah on
the yeah when it first happened you are the kind of girl to
play yeah and then i and then um and i got not i became the
queen and they went up to me i think i got knocked up i was
like they were like are you the queen did you play a lot of
the art no no i was just like hanging out with a friend that
told me to get on because he was Ooh, what is all so
terrible.
What is that?
There's a party.
Inviting us to a party.
Did you not get the invite?
No, I didn't.
Oh, don't worry.
You can be my plus one.
Oh, there's a...
So I got to hit the valve?
Oh, he hit it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, parkour.
Oh, my God.
I messed up.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Just be behind me.
All right, it's okay.
We can wait here.
Just edge it.
Just be right.
Okay.
I was trying to get further than you.
Someone got a little greedy.
Yeah.
Okay.
Maybe we get too close to this.
Let's not edge it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's too close to the sun.
Oh, I thought you'd get so hard right now.
I see you get closer.
I was like, I want to be closer, too.
This is like a testosterone, like, fight.
Who's going to go badly?
Oh, yeah, I get closer to this.
It's like, it's like chicken.
We're playing chicken right now.
Oh, there you go.
It's like, it's edged chicken.
It's edged chicken right now.
I'm edging my chicken right now.
I'm edging my chicken.
closer okay okay let's think you take this seriously okay
closer than that yes yeah you can't you can't get closer to
that oh yeah bet bet oh my god you What?
See how it went!
Ah!
Fucking fuck!
Fuck!
You fuck!
Okay.
Maybe I'll be closer.
I'll be closer.
I'll pull...
Oh, motherfucker.
We saw what happened when you were closer.
Guys, get behind me.
Okay, you edge, you edge.
Okay, get...
Oh, that's pretty close, but I can get closer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think.
Okay, okay, okay.
Deep breath, deep breath.
Get closer.
You can go closer.
Yeah.
Yeah, I am.
No, no, no.
I just, I just want to be a little closer.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
We take this seriously.
We don't need it.
We start now.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to cheat.
Okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Go.
Oh my god Make the slide make the slide Oh my god, oh my
god, my god is still right behind us.
He's still right behind us.
Come on.
Come on get quick.
Get further I don't want to die.
I want to edge someone Okay, all right.
Oh, we made it again.
We were elevator.
We were supposed to do something else No, it's okay.
It's automatic.
We did it.
Look at us.
We won we won we won edge chicken oh oh maybe we do you know
mags 21 that little thing kind of looks like it's because
he's bug is it oh no what's he doing oh my god that was so
funny i almost threw up that was just like we're like so
dumb oh wait oh wait oh you're trapped wait you're trapped
in He didn't get me.
See, I won edge chicken.
You did.
I edged too close.
Yeah, you edged too close.
Oh.
You're about to be his other puppet.
What do I do here?
I like it in here, actually.
It's kind of nice.
Yeah, you don't have to do any work.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's a ladder.
The ladder.
Oh, yeah.
Do I just...
Wait.
Iskeleta?
Maybe wait for him to leave All right.
Oh, wait.
You see his little friend?
There's the little guy next to him Are you shooting?
Wait, shoot him.
Oh, oh you are
Yeah, that's right.
Sorry keep shooting.
Keep shooting him.
Okay.
I can't.
Are you fucking okay?
I could I could shoot.
No, no, I know but like okay How fast do I have to can I
run?
Maybe maybe I hope I don't know if I can run just remember
the edging okay okay how could i forget i was a winner all
right wait i'll wait hey you ugly you ugly oh i have to yeah
yeah yeah yeah i just accepted my fate all right the moment
he turns around i can start crawling
you got this yeah i got this i believe yeah i feel bad this
part's so hard for you yeah yeah i just sit here okay i
think i'm gonna wait again i fucked up i hesitated no i
hesitated i gotta wait
hello hello hello hello all right don't worry i'll do it
again all right
oh okay dude they're getting pissed at me oh my god I'm
walking as fast as I don't know how many times he shakes it
okay all right you gotta do it again so I can crank it hey
hey okay good hopefully that doesn't lower me What?
Oh.
I guess that made really loud noise.
When do I lower it?
Interestante.
So interesting.
All right.
I feel so, I feel, dude, I wish I could help.
Oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, he's stuck.
piece of piggy that was just like oh that's over for me well
accepting my feet all right here we go
you okay yeah yeah i have to grab a cough drop dude i'll
have one too all right yeah oh yeah that's true that's true
we're using our power up we have power we're locked in oh
freak this one melted in all right It's so hot in here.
Okay, here's the one.
All right.
Okay, let's try it.
I'm not even wrestling with this pop drop.
All right.
I'll get a different one.
When you are cranking?
Oh, I'm not even getting it.
It's the last one.
What the heck?
When do I crank the soldier, boy?
There you go.
I got it.
Oh, maybe I crank it when you...
Yeah.
Do I...
When do I crank it?
Wait, for him to start shaking me, maybe?
Wait, I know.
I know.
Okay, so...
I think the crank, oh, the crank is for yours.
Because you're supposed to shoot the guy, the rope up top
later.
So after he leaves, I crank it.
Yeah, when he goes back, yeah, when he's at the table.
I thought the crank was for the other guy.
But it's for you.
Do you want me to keep the track?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No distraction, no distractions.
I'll start cranking it.
Oh, it's coming this way.
And I think I shoot that guy in the jar.
I don't want to know if he, oh, okay.
if he turns around or does he like just does writing his
like autobiography i think he's writing fan fiction or
something yeah he's writing some sick ass fan fiction right
now like some naruto assassination oh my god my little
sister used to drop fan art of them oh my god was it good
yeah it i have a photo of it on my phone oh my god wait okay
okay here will i be okay there we go I kind of shot that
without asking.
I almost killed you.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to go down.
Yeah, yeah, the ladder.
All right, I'm coming up.
Look at that.
I'm going up.
All right, I'm going to make this jump.
Watch this.
That was good depth perception.
Look at that.
Boom!
I had a good meal today.
Yes!
Yippee!
I hate these motherfuckers, the little crawly guy.
Oh yeah, no, me too.
Alright.
Here.
The doggie door.
Who builds all these houses?
I believe the other... Oh, you want to take a spooky dookie?
Ooh!
They clogged the toilet.
They took a spookier dookie.
I'll go do it in the crowd then.
There's a mop there.
Oh!
This is a nice area.
This is nice.
I feel like someone's going to come in here.
Yeah, I think so, too.
What is there, like, a freaking elf in there?
What is that?
It's, um...
Wait, what the fuck was this guy?
It's Peter Pan!
Wait, there's...
They're like us.
But we look better.
Yeah, we...
Oh, wait, wait, we push.
We push.
Oh, okay.
Wait, we pull?
Oh, push.
Wait, do we push or pull?
I'll push first.
Oh, maybe the...
No, no, no, pull.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do I do with you, little boy?
Oh!
I'm breaking this radio.
Wait, there's a...
Look, see?
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Boom.
Just hiding that.
So greedy.
Hiding that from us.
Selfish.
Yeah, so selfish.
Wow.
This is why we didn't get caught.
sorry it's all the edging it makes me gas yeah you're just
all the all the anxiety bubbling up anxiety oh oh no where
am i i don't know i think you're in that corner am i in a
corner oh i'm here i'm here i'm here oh no oh no our food
that was our dinner but like he when it's fresh though you
know yeah five second yeah but like you like taste the blood
and like the exactly it doesn't taste as good wait but we
can eat it now really yeah let's go all right all right i'm
young oh i'm i'm mashing it up for you i'm mashing up don't
worry i know your baby teeth thank you you pre-chew my food
yeah exactly Wait, wait.
Oh,
do we go over here?
I have no idea.
Where the fuck do we go?
You just gravitate to the chairs in the corner.
Yeah, because it's in the corridor.
I'll go look over here.
Okay.
There must be something we're missing.
Huh?
Where am I?
I'm here.
That was you.
All right.
Let's...
You push together?
Oh, maybe.
No.
Too heavy.
Someone said there's a ladder?
I don't see no ladder.
I see this, but...
Can you move the chair?
I think so.
No, we can climb the chair.
Oh, wait.
Is there a hole behind the chair?
No, it's not shadowing.
No, no, no.
The hedgehog.
Oh, I have to.
hear knocking is it you i'm outside right now no no what the
should like turn on my way wait where's my flashlight where
did my flashlight go up your butt can we not touch the
mirror i guess because it's broken right yeah it's a broken
mirror Yeah, this one's broken, too.
Nothing here.
There's an up-ease on the boxes in the corner.
Which boxes?
There's so many boxes.
This box?
No up-ease?
Up-ease?
Oh, these boxes?
Here, these boxes?
Is there an up-ease?
Oh, I knew it.
I was like, I was like, that looks like something you can
climb, you know?
Like the...
I didn't realize that...
Okay.
I'll be back.
I'll wait here.
I feel like I should wait underneath this chair.
See, you keep going back.
The chair's in the corner.
Yeah, because this is in the corner.
What else would you do with a chair in the corner, you know?
What else am I supposed to do with a chair in the corner?
He's in the room next to you.
Oh, he's coming in.
He's coming in.
I gotta make this jump.
what did you die you died really come on okay no no no no no
no it fade to black so you don't know what happened to my
body no you don't know what happened to my body where do i
hide come on i don't figure i don't figure out where to hide
first before wait wait i need to figure it out where the
fuck do i hide behind the door i saw you could go behind the
painting yeah this one I went behind this one.
Yeah, I would...
From the side you can go in there.
Maybe?
Yeah, I'll try here.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
I'll let you know what he does.
All right.
Oh, but you gotta help me up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll help you up and I'll run behind the painting.
Gracias.
All right, upies.
Get up.
Hey.
Okay.
All right.
All right, tell me when you're good to go and I'll go up.
Okay, okay.
No, I'm good to go.
I'm good to go.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I got an idea.
She got out of here.
Actually, maybe I will do your mirror thing.
Alright, I'm behind the mirror.
There's no way he'll know.
There's no way.
I'm so safe right now.
Chat, do I have to jump on this thing?
Because there's no way.
I have no perception.
Well, I think you have to do something.
For him, he's just, like, walking around, so.
He's chilling?
Yeah, he's just chilling.
Oh?
Oh, there's a beam.
Oh, can I walk on this?
Oh, I think he's gone.
Wait, he's gone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
There's a hole.
Wait, I hear your footsteps.
Where are you?
I'm upstairs.
I think I gotta keep going.
I'm just chilling.
Oh, yes, there's a lever.
I think this should do something for you.
Alright.
I'm waiting.
Okay, I'm cranking it.
Crank that soldier boy?
Oh, it's lowering in the door, the room you're in right now.
Oh, I see it.
Malady?
There you go.
I'm gripping it.
Oh, yeah, I keep doing it.
Yeah, keep lowering it.
Keep lowering it.
I'm only...
Keep...
You're almost there.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Okay.
Come on.
I'm hanging.
Don't let go.
On the chandelier.
Oh.
Oh, good job.
Oh, wait, this is a nice place.
Yeah.
Wait, where do we go from here?
I don't know.
Oh, wait, now I have my flashlight.
Wait, man.
This is where I came from.
I don't know if we're supposed to go this way.
Okay, I gotta make sure.
Yeah, I think it's something over there.
This is all right.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, no!
Someone should have been a little patient.
I'm gonna summon him.
Alright, go do it.
Do what you want, pussy.
I have what I eat!
Do it!
Do it, do it, pussy.
I got this.
It's a long climb.
I'm waiting.
I'm AFKing.
Alright, I'm almost there.
Okay, I'm going.
He's coming.
Alright.
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know, still.
Okay, I'm about to crank the soldier boy.
Yeah.
Not yet, not yet.
Alright, crank it.
Crank that soldier boy.
Okay, I'm coming.
Alright, I'm cranking it.
Crank it.
Crank it!
Yo!
Crank that soldier boy!
I'm undoing the cranking?
Uncrank that, yeah.
Uncrank that soldier boy.
Do it in reverse.
I'm hitting the stinky leg.
Alright, now can we push this?
Yeah.
No, we're still too weak.
No, there's handprints on it.
I think we do.
Oh, oh, oh, we just... Okay, okay, we just gotta wait.
That was our yellow paint.
Yeah, that was our yellow paint.
It wasn't yellow, so how was we supposed to know it?
You know?
I don't know?
Uh-oh.
I'm not scared.
Yeah.
He's gonna do wake up.
What is he gonna do?
He's drunk.
Chat with my uncle.
Let's go.
I don't like this door.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, he's gonna come out of that door, isn't he?
It's time.
Please don't send us all the way back.
No, please.
Please don't.
Please.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Like she's yelling in this game is so funny.
Do I just wait?
I need to just wait for you.
Wait, where is it?
Where is it?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Jump over my head.
AB, go.
Go, then.
Guys, why the fuck?
You don't.
I have no idea.
Just jump.
Just jump and trust, trust the process.
Trust the, yeah, trust.
You don't need a job.
my screen okay to be fair on my screen there was no handle
and oh wait the dokey skip the dokey by the way you had no
rope that guy was like was like slowly submerging into the
wall like no no that guy he was literally going low slower
and lower into the wall oh my gosh I got this A dokey skip
It always works He's training him to be a juggler Oh, he
thinks you're a rat That's so embarrassing Hmm, if only
someone Trigger the rat I'm trying to do a dokey skip again
It's so cool Okay, how did you trigger the rat I think by
touching the carpet And getting over here
oh look your son's a failure look at him yeah look at him
can't even struggle take away his food privileges oh oh he's
getting him new tricks oh what's that that's a key what's
that key for these wait not yet he's like learn a new trick
son not everyone can be a juggler How do we get that?
I don't know.
Do we go this way?
He's a mouth-breathing.
Just like me, for real, for real.
I think the older you get, the more you mouth-breathe.
I do have a deviated septum, so sometimes it do be like
that.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Will he see us?
Can he see us?
Nah, we're good.
I wonder what that key was for.
Nah, it can't be that important.
Maybe it's for the story.
Okay.
Oh, we probably have to get it on the way back or something.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I'll...
All right, up these.
Okay.
Oh, up these.
Yeah.
What?
Oh, elevator.
Oh, okay, bye.
I guess that was a secret.
I think we'll be back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
here yeah yeah oh yeah we're definitely going back because
we're on the second floor oh wait yeah see oh can you see
the rope on your screen a what on my screen yeah i can see
it okay cool cool well you first oh wait wait he's gonna
he's gonna come take me back dodge how's it i'm gonna say um
i'm pretty sure he's all I'm almost done with the jungle.
I've been through all this entire animation.
And according to my calculation, she's about to loop and
turn around.
You do it.
You're a pro.
You know what you're doing.
All right.
Watch this.
Okay, we got to watch him fail first.
Don't get him.
Disappoint your father.
Disappoint him.
Be a failure.
I would never do that, right, Dad?
Oh, no.
Oh, sorry.
What did you ask me?
Wait.
Were you on the road?
Did you drop down?
No, I'm...
All right.
Watch this.
Yeah, I can do it.
Remember your times in the circus.
All right.
We gotta watch him fail first.
Fail.
Daddy don't love you no more.
Yeah.
Daddy never loved you.
Come on.
Make him ashamed of you.
Make him wish he...
You disappointment.
No more dinner.
No more dinner for you.
Don't worry.
You may not be meant to be a juggler.
Be a VTuber.
Yeah.
It might actually be easier.
Now he's got the rings.
Watch this.
This is so slow.
Okay,
then you gotta sneak like...
backed up.
Yeah.
You're so good at this game.
Yeah, you see that?
Yeah.
I'll meet you over there.
Okay, I gotta watch him be a failure again.
I gotta learn from... I gotta take lessons from this guy.
He can't do anything right.
Look at that.
Yeah, look at him.
Lose it!
Yeah.
See, it's fun to watch seeing another child being in
disappointment, isn't it?
It's great.
I feel better about myself.
Yeah, exactly.
Even though... At least you're not like him, right?
Yeah, I can juggle.
Yeah.
Alright.
We've got this.
Oh, now he's got...
Back to the ball.
He's like, maybe we can make this work.
Wait, was I supposed to go down with you?
Oh.
No, there's an escalator.
We're good.
Wait, but no?
Because how am I gonna...
Oh, feck, I gotta come down with...
How am I gonna open the little panel?
This is bad.
I have to go...
Okay, I've got to wait for him to be a failure.
And then...
The dokey strat.
Wait for a kid to hate his life.
And then you go.
I bought this for you.
Swing, bud, about a thing.
You freaking failure.
Oh.
What?
Wait, me?
Wait, what?
What did you do?
How did you see me?
We need a doki skip ASAP.
Yeah, we need a doki.
a dokey skip all right now okay now now you saw how i got
the key you can you can repeat it yeah i'm not gonna wait
i'm just gonna go this has to be the slowest thing i've ever
seen i jumped out jump up yeah yeah yeah and then i'm gonna
kill your kid i'm gonna kill your kid you friend
all right i'm so bad at this point no no you got this you
saw how I got it.
You saw how your old man did it.
You could do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just you know, you don't want to be a disappointment like
that man's son.
Okay, so I gotta wait for him to fail?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait for him to fail and then take the rope.
Yeah, don't be a disappointment like this guy.
Can't even fucking juggle.
See, mine is slow and long.
Look, I'm too old.
Wait, we missed her, okay, we almost missed her Q, okay,
wait.
All right, all right.
Getting ready.
Did you see the confidence in my jump?
Yeah, he's like, I'm ready.
I think you got a little too distracted there.
I think I'm okay.
All right, you can, round three, round three, I believe in
you.
You want to play Icky Plank?
We're trying to pass the time, you know?
We're just passing the time.
We got addicted to edging.
We did it earlier.
We failed.
He failed.
Okay, okay, good.
Daddy don't love you.
Yeah.
My dad.
Can't do none.
Okay, tell me when.
Tell me when.
Okay.
Now.
It's lagging.
I'm going to fix this.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll show you how I showed you how I did it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm going to show you how it's done.
Okay.
Okay, you ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, now we gotta wait.
Well.
Okay.
why are you so close but yeah personal space personal space
wait you're right aren't you the host I want to find
something to throw at him
go queen I think it's because I didn't sprint oops mm-hmm I
wish we could both get on that
good job
all right you're almost your turn soon all right tell me
when all right shoot arrows at him I can't I can't use my
bow I'm jaking it all right he's a failure yep yep that's
why that's why his mom left him his mom left him when he was
born the mom is the puppet actually oh you're right yeah the
he came out of that hole Yeah.
All right.
Tell me when.
Okay.
I did it.
Nice.
I am descending from the heavens.
All right.
Remember to wait and don't jump down.
Don't jump.
Not just, okay.
Okay.
And then we wait.
Yes.
We wait for him to fail.
We wait.
Yeah, exactly.
It's gonna be easy.
It happens very easily.
I don't want to chuck that ball out of him, though.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
This is the furthest we've ever got.
This is the furthest team.
Remember when I say it's very easy to disappoint fathers?
Oh, fake you're right.
I got a lock in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
All right.
He's going to fail right here.
Oh, there we go.
You suck.
No one loves you.
That's right.
That's why your mom left you.
Oh, wait, no, actually, no.
Pull out the hoops if you hate your kid.
oh we're almost there we're almost there all right we go we
go we go we go we go notice he pulled out the hoops I'm just
saying all right we're almost there we're almost there oh my
gosh we are the best all right here we go here go go go grip
it grip it grip it all right can you go first I'll be behind
oh no it's okay yeah all right please auto save Boom!
It's it.
Okay, cool, cool.
Alright.
I got the key.
Yippee.
Alright.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
I'm always a dog!
Was there a freaking dog?
Was it...
You know...
Okay, now we can go.
You know what they say.
It's very easy to disappoint.
We know I'm gonna hit... Look, I'm gonna...
They're gonna come in.
They're gonna trip on us.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like the marbles.
Like the marbles trap.
You're like home alone.
You remind me of that kid that we saw that couldn't jump.
struggle.
What?
I don't know.
Going second sucks.
You waited to see if I'd fall.
I know what the figure...
Of course not.
No, I just wanted to see if...
No, of course not.
I would never.
I was just waiting for you, you know, making sure you catch
up.
A father will never abandon their kids.
They always come back.
Okay, baby steps.
Jimmy baby steps We got We got Stinks Wait Do I Okay We got
Push it I don't think so Oh I got That's because I got a
shoe In my hand Okay cool Oh Okay The shoe The shoe was
blocked You know what Oh sweet I kept my shoe It's a theater
Wait what is it It's a theater Huh?
Oh well A theater Yeah A theater Yeah It's a theater Oh You
mispronounced The name of this room And you us die.
A idiot.
What do we do here?
Alright, get the shoe out of here.
Nah, I love it.
Yeah, I see you love it too.
Oh, maybe we crouch?
I don't think that's true.
I hear him too.
This way!
Doki bird!
Oh my god, it was this way.
you tell me sooner like oh my god oh my god oh my god what
do you mean there's people what do you mean
it's like i'm taking my grandma on a walk through ikea she's
dimension she keeps forgetting where the fiction is we're
back do i go right wow tv why are we going yeah all right
okay now we know Now we know, okay, okay, he's like the rock
from Indiana Jones Yeah, don't drop your hat Don't drop your
hat Yeah, don't drop the hat I'm doing the tech I'm doing
the tech Toki tech Toki tech Look at that, look, I'm
actually a bit faster than you Look at that Yeah, it's like
Minecraft You gotta sprint and jump This way, this way Oh,
you gotta break the door Break the door Break the door Oh,
I'm distracted What's that?
Oh my god, who's faster?
faster i think he's faster i think he's faster i think he's
okay okay oh i have to smell this room again i just want to
get my cardio in you know when's the last time you've worked
out i feel like you're like in shape like oh i got i was
sick for a week i think like two weeks ago when i wasn't oh
wait that's so embarrassing i haven't worked out since high
school You know, go, you know, getting out of bed is
considered working out for some people.
Gaming is a workout for my eyes.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Like, you're, you're, you're focusing your abdominal, like,
you know, your abdomen and stuff and everything.
Oh my god.
Okay, here you go.
This part is scary.
Okay.
Button, button, button, button.
This is your turn, your turn.
All right.
Oh, sheave your bow!
Sheave your bow!
Get out!
Okay.
Oh,
careful, careful.
That's right, we got our 20 eggs.
Oh, what is he gonna do?
Chase us?
That's right.
Oh, oh, he's gonna shoot us.
Oh, he's gonna shoot us, oh my God.
He's gonna shoot us.
That's worse, that's worse.
Oh, oh, that's five.
The kid is here.
I gotta shoot him.
what do we do no
oh no is that the button oh that's the button that's the
button yeah I got it I shaped it this time let's go are you
are you are you are you okay my hands I forgot I ate a
McChicken they were a little juicy Yeah, yeah, yeah, you
just let me know.
I got it.
All right, I look my fingers.
Yeah, yeah, right.
I mean, you're looking good.
Okay.
Instantly forgot.
All right.
What the frick is happening?
Someone, someone didn't lick up, lick off all the grease.
I missed the fingers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just the, you know, one inch of grease on your pinky.
Yeah, yeah.
The one inch on the pinky.
Yeah, exactly.
You only had four fingers.
How were you going to climb that with four fingers?
Four big fingers.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
Guys, easiest, easiest part of the game.
Don't worry, I'll wait for you.
I'm so freaking... There you are.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I'm waiting for you.
I'm waiting for you.
Just keep gripping it.
Just gripping it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do we... Oh, do we...
Oh, we gotta guard it when he's up there.
We gotta grab the thing.
Can we just grab it early?
Yeah, I think so.
grab it grab it there we go yeah yeah there we go that's
right we killed your wife we're gonna stick that in now no
yeah exactly oh that's right i found a new wife why why does
our airplane have a ball sack i think that's like i think
that's meat i think that's our food you know dinner He's got
a hand on the bottom.
Yeah, it's dinner for tonight.
Oh, that's what Uber eats.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, we're Uber eating right now.
We got, uh, we got delivery for, uh, Chaka Chihara?
Yeah, yeah.
I would never eat a whole pizza by myself.
That is a reference two people will get.
That's for those two people.
Right there.
Representing you.
Chaka.
Oh, uh, there's other air balloons.
Hello?
Are they just like us?
I don't know.
Maybe they're full of like...
Oh, they're empty, I think.
Where are they going?
It's a crispy.
Hello?
Oh!
Oh, no.
Even God hates us.
It's a very bad day.
Oh!
It was all a dream!
Wait, whose dream is it?
Wait, who's not real?
Dude, that hair is sick.
It looks like yarn.
Yeah, it's cute.
I like it.
Yeah.
Okay, but who's that kid?
Is it me or you?
I don't know, because we were both masked either.
That's true.
You don't know what's behind my mask.
Oh, no.
It's the dream theory.
It's always the coma theory or the dream theory.
Oh, you brought up masks and then you dream i thought yeah i
was like look he's actually dream yeah what the mask is so
one of us is the voices yeah who is it we're in this rubber
room yeah yeah it's the padded room i think we're about to
see on this piece of paper who's uh oh uh please don't be me
i please i i i
was the imaginary friend well the character i was playing
got pissed off maybe he realized Oh.
Oh.
I think.
I think you're the crazy one.
Not crazy.
Because like, you know how we both got caught?
But then somehow, you know, when you were in that jail cell,
even though I got caught at the same time as you?
Yeah.
But yes, somehow I was outside the jail cell.
How long is this game?
I think we're at the final arc.
This has to be the final arc.
We found out you're crazy.
I've been only gonna piss for two hours.
Okay, I think you gotta pee.
It towers me.
Oh my god, you're just teleporting.
What the?
There you go.
Oh, you're going crazy already.
You're going crazy already.
Doki?
You're going crazy.
What do you mean?
I've been watching you play this entire time.
This is a single-player game.
What are you talking about?
Don't keep hurting.
What do you see right now?
I'm watching your game right now.
You're screen sharing.
Because it's a single-player game, GB.
What?
Yeah.
I'm pulling up your stream.
What the fuck do you see right now?
your pause the game if i get an ad if i get an ad on your
stream we're done what i'll see what you see what do you see
what the are you doing nothing nothing where are you what
the is happening where are you what is happening where are
you doki's chat look at my screen what are you what are you
looking at what are you you're like jumping for joy oh my
god you're back what did you do oh my god what the heck you
really are fake yeah this is no night no nightmare story is
a single player game what are you talking about what the
heck is happening i don't know where to go wait we have
flashlight also i gave you plus one viewer i have your
stream open so that'll be 10 Oh, shit.
That's, that's like more expensive than viewbotting.
I got it.
All right, here we go.
Oh, no.
Oh, I don't like that sound.
This poppy playtime with all these chase sequences.
Topical joke.
Hit that like button.
Please, I'm so freaking wrong.
all right nice oh the building's collapsing this place is
not safe for work oh my god that's so cute
i thought he was like a cute yeah when he opened up when he
opened the flower he was just trying to say hi is that this
is why this is why i'm a vegan not because i love animals
because i hate nature don't cut out let me shoot it shoot it
shoot the eye there you go oh no oh yeah yeah see that but
plants what the plants do for us yeah exactly you need to
put like a parking lot here some asphalt all right let's go
wait oh maybe up here yeah yeah there's a window through the
window to the window to the wall
Oh, maybe up here, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shoot a plant.
There's just another plant there.
I hate that freaking plant.
Shoot it.
Oh, wait, you can't.
I'll shoot it at another moment.
When at least expected.
Oh, we did.
Oh, we...
Can we shoot it when we're over there?
Tease it.
What do we do when it opens up?
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, I got an idea.
Okay, go back, go back.
You're... I'm supposed to to open it up and then you shoot
it.
I'm not going.
I'm not walking back.
The freak, this is faster.
I'm killing myself.
Speed run.
Okay.
All right, is this the...
Okay, nice, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
The dokey skip.
All right, yeah, you go across.
Okay, okay, here.
You gotta, you gotta, like, bait this guy.
Like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
I'm really good at baiting.
Photosynthesizing my pylon.
What is it called?
The what?
The mitochondria?
What's it called?
It's a mitochondria?
There you go.
Now you come over.
You guys know like the piston.
The piston.
You were like, oh, I'm...
A piston?
What?
My piston?
I'm stuck on...
Doki, Doki up!
Doki, Doki!
Just trust.
Oh my god, Doki!
Believe.
Look, I'm looking.
I'm looking over.
Just... Okay, you got it.
Got it.
I see you gripping it.
And just move to the left.
Do you hear this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just go to the left.
Just... Oh, oh, jump up.
Jump up.
Grip it.
I can't move.
I can't jump.
Go to the left a little bit edge a little bit jump up Okay,
okay, okay.
Yeah, but don't be afraid.
Okay.
Yeah, and then grip it and then don't be afraid Do not be
afraid child.
You're not Such good advice That's it.
All right Believe in yourself Did it believe like a plant?
Oh, wow.
Comedy Central just jump why are you tough you're like my
haters do you see that woman covered in mushrooms yeah I saw
that I think it's last of us it's pre last of us oh here
here oh oh yeah boom wait can I oh there you have to be
beside you find me first oh wait crouched a dentist I don't
think he sees us I want to get my exam I actually have Mine
is coming up every six months, so.
Oh.
It's alright.
He's blind.
Can I grab his balls?
She be there.
The door?
You want to pee, don't you?
You want to pee?
Oh.
I did.
I did what I was told.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Okay, never mind.
We're back with the granny.
Was there anything here?
Maybe?
Wait, no.
That's where we came from.
how do you do with the doctor then i'm waiting for you make
sure you crouch i'm in the doctor room how did you get in
the doctor room put the through the tunnel
yeah i think he i think it's the same he goes off of sound
what are you coming i need your help there's like a doggy
door how did you how did you How did you...
I just get it!
It's gonna be like how did you get through?
I was like...
I'm jacking off.
It's freaking screaming, dude.
Whatever, man.
Whatever.
Y'all can see, that's a strong-ass doggy door.
Who got this?
All right, just stab.
Just stab.
All right, I got this.
GB died doing what she loves, jorking it.
I just...
We just addicted to edging.
Oh, maybe I gotta throw the bottle to distract him.
Hold on, I got this.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go ahead, go ahead to the door.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God, he is blind.
I'm not gonna be ableist but I will call him stupid okay I
need your help for this I need you to oh we should oh I
gotta hit that gone boom okay wait what do we I got it oh I
don't think wait what am I gonna do Oh, the gun!
Oh.
Hit that gun.
Hit that gun!
Oh!
Oh, that was a good gun.
That's a good ass gun.
What is that?
Why is that a snake?
I like snakes.
I'm actually not scared of them.
They're cute.
Oh, wait.
I think that's a finger.
Are we the butthole?
Do you see the lines?
Do you see the lines on that?
That looks like fingerprints.
Oh, oh.
Oh,
there's a kid there.
Did Dad also hate you?
He's stealing your block.
He got nothing.
Wait, where's the kid?
He killed himself.
Oh, I did not see a kid.
What are you talking about?
There's no kids here.
I fell through.
I am stuck.
the floor i need oh my okay don't worry i'm stuck i'll push
you there oh no it's okay oh dang it we fixed it we fixed it
we fixed it we fixed it okay well this is what's happened
okay well i think oh i give you a piece here yeah wait
you're so intelligent oh no no no no no we're just holding
hands.
Oh, is there anything else?
Oh, maybe up he's here?
I do it.
No?
I don't think so.
Maybe there's stuff we missed behind us.
Oh, he cleared up this way.
Yeah, I saw it.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a lever.
Where is it?
Oh, there's another hole.
There's another... Oh, wait, you're right.
Well... Oh, there's another hole here.
Oh.
Are you gonna explore?
Be back when the street lights turn on, okay?
don't worry i'll be back i'll you told me i'm traveling
right now i'm fast traveled you know wait where are you
where did you go i fast traveled you did yeah hello oh hey
yeah i fast traveled backwards what do we do over here we
jump over yeah i don't think we can wait can you can you
shoot
Oh, you're fast traveling, too.
Oh, the elevator is here.
Oh, frick.
Alright, I'll wait for you at the elevator.
Don't worry.
I have upies.
Upies here.
Hey.
Yeah.
We're all gonna moonwalk it.
I don't think you can walk backwards.
Hey.
Alright.
Get that lever in.
I'm so proud of us.
We're doing pretty good.
Now we're making progress.
This has to be the last arc.
We found out you're crazy.
It has to be endgame.
I'm crazy full of piss.
The piss is what's making you crazy.
Yeah.
The more piss you have, the less room for anything else.
Stored in the balls.
Yeah.
anything on this side?
No, upies here.
Wait, that means we- oh, that means we have to hide in there
later.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a light here.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I got a lag switch.
Me too.
It, like, froze for a second.
Oh, wait, upies?
Maybe?
No?
No, I don't think so.
Wait, oh, that's where we get the light.
Ow!
Everything I've touched dies.
Here, here, here, here.
Oh, blind.
Boom.
I saw a handle.
Handle.
Alright.
Uppies.
Ew!
This room's stinky.
What's wrong with the room?
It's stinky.
So we won't end in shower.
i'm heading out wait there's a there's a seesaw here i'm
heading out i found an invisible one i'm gonna get a cop
drop is your throat okay yeah i'm i'm cool i just got i was
i've been sick so oh no wait right here here all right ready
oh oh oh i guess oh never mind I'm too thick.
Never mind.
Let's see.
I don't think...
Oh, you need a key.
Yeah, I don't think we have to go forward.
There's stuff on the front.
Okay.
Wait, did we didn't...
Yeah, there we go.
Wait, is this a pit?
That's a pit, right?
Okay.
How could we have known that was a pit?
Alright.
Oh my god, I came back to life-playing hopscotch.
Oh, we go forward.
Right here.
The pit?
No, no, turn around.
Turn around.
Oh, I went down there.
There's a dead end.
Oh, what?
Yeah, maybe it was a different end?
Yeah, but it is dead end.
What the fuck were we doing?
Oh, wait, no.
There's a door right here.
Oh, blind.
Oh?
I love this show.
Oh my god.
Bill Cipher.
Illuminati.
What do we do here?
We're supposed to do something here?
I don't know, but I got a sick car!
Okay, I can't...
Can't do anything to that.
What the fuck is that supposed to be?
Stupid TV!
I don't want TV.
I want to play on my Xbox.
Yeah.
I'm playing Neal Pets.
I gotta feed my side bunny or she's gonna die.
I have a a Neal Pets stuffed animal.
Oh, me too.
I used to have, like, a bunch of them from the McDonald's
when they did the McDonald's promotion.
Yeah, I love her that.
That's how I discovered Neal Pets.
I feel like it has to be something on the other room, right?
Yeah.
The Seesaw Room?
Are we missing something in the Seesaw room?
Oh, maybe I start hammering?
Oh, get hammered.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I can't...
Okay.
I can't bring up my hammer in the seesaw room.
Wait, unless...
No, I used my hammer.
Too many rooms.
Brain hurt.
Too many cooks.
Oh, up here?
Where?
Maybe I can shoot that dog.
Oh, wait, yeah.
Oh, we're blind.
We're blind.
Okay, there's a thing.
Look, there's were so many holes.
How could we have known that was the right hole?
Exactly.
It's harder than it looks.
Yeah, yeah.
It's so hard.
Oh, that's where you live.
This is your crazy home.
It brings back a lot of memories.
It's really nice to be back.
This is where I'll met you.
Oh, there's my toys.
That's how I met you!
I'm like, wait, that's me.
Whoa.
Wow, I love this.
Is that your mom?
For mine, it's gonna be a wonderful day.
The gift of second set.
Oh, this is you, you can have it.
Oh, I think we were supposed to hide under the bed.
Oh.
Damn, she's taking so long to get here.
Mom?
Is she stuck?
I'm scared.
Wait, is she stuck?
Only then I go to bed.
Sleepy time.
I think she's stuck.
Should we open this again?
No, I think we just leave.
Oh, the plushie makes things.
different wait does it yeah keep carrying it oh the light is
different now yeah oh it's like happier wait look over here
go here here i took my meds oh oh no don't forget okay wait
wait bring me a plushie like bring it bring it we have to
jump through this i gotta throw it to you and i jump okay
ready catch all right chuck it through the hole
all right just walk yeah walk through the normal way okay
wait uh oops i didn't really do much i think only you can
grab it i don't do you think the pit will be covered wait we
can go back to tv go back to tv yeah they're playing like
icar yeah yeah yeah maybe they're cartoon networks on oh
foster's home yeah yeah
yeah i'm watching adventure time what's on the tv oh mother
oh they didn't know tv time
no someone was a bad kid i only bit my mom once yeah just
one time don't hurt nobody except for my mom there's a
freaking fish what you want to see my freaking Where is it?
There's a freaking fish.
Oh my god, there's a fish!
Fyosh.
I wonder if it's still alive.
This way?
Left side?
Oh, this is closed with the light on.
What's in here?
With the light on?
How much happier is this place?
Oh, it's another movie.
Oh, this is open.
Oh, there's no other here.
What?
Oh, jump
I think this doll is laced with acid But then like Oh yeah,
when we both touch it, it goes through Both of our skins
We're having the same trip right now I feel like we're about
to be chased by something Me too This feels very...
Oh, it's light!
We need that Okay, yeah, it's for me
Yeah, it's for me Yeah, yeah Oh, there's no floor in here
Yeah, yeah, yeah But we need to make sure that you hold that
you oh wait you gotta pull this yeah i gotta here up he's
all right and then we gotta go all the way back
oh the pit's right here i didn't even notice yeah yeah yeah
and i could put the light it was the light again it was i
have no idea i don't remember i know we saw it was it back
here it wasn't right tricycle because that's tv no yeah
let's wait or do we oh oh i feel like we should be fine
where i'm gonna where was the light again don't remember i
think it's so much but what's up here remember when the
light you said there was no light if the light is gone from
here it opens up oh no no no i think it's i think i'm dumb
i'm here was it back there but that was a door though right
that's oh maybe it's in there but it's locked with the light
to the left is anything okay uh i let i don't think i'm
supposed to doll my character started freaking out uh i do
not know where the light is wait um i can't get through the
door can't get through the oh okay there you then i guess uh
wait wait can you move up a bit yeah where is back here was
it back here no Where the fuck is the...
Where do we put this?
Butthole.
What?
I swear we saw it.
Did we not see it switch?
I'm gonna wait for you to run away.
I'm checking.
This is the TV.
Yeah, you look without me because I think maybe I'm changing
things.
Oh, oh my god, tripped.
Where's my light?
Oh, there it is.
You have it?
No, no, I tripped and dropped my thing.
Hey.
Stupid plushie.
What?
Alright, I'll wait for you over here.
Maybe there has to be something on this.
We got this on.
Okay.
Where did we get?
Oh, my gosh.
Where the fuck is it?
Was this door open?
Oh, wait.
Is this door open?
no whoa oh wait the light what the fuck wait get closer this
disappears too so it has to be a door that was like here
before can't be here because that's where we got it yeah
that's where we got it
oh almost ran into that oh my god oops i dropped it i need
help
Oh, wait, wait, leave?
Okay, I got it.
That's a part of the real world.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, we don't know where it is.
We don't, we're so lost.
We're so fucking lost.
Where is it?
Where is the light?
Oh, where is it?
This is the fish's fault.
I don't know where to go.
I'll wait here.
What if it's... what if it's back there?
Oh, I think it was, actually.
Maybe?
Okay.
Like, oh, come back, come back then.
Oh, I can't with the plushie.
Oh!
I'll try dropping it.
Let's see what happens.
You can't, because we need to...
We can't go through the door without it.
Oh, you think so?
Yeah, yeah, because like, we need to...
Chat.
We need help.
We...
Chat.
Oh, go through the door on the right?
There's that TV time.
What?
This door?
Yeah.
Anything in there?
There's no batteries sitting here.
I'm looking.
Hmm.
Door on the right at the end of the hallway.
Wait.
There's a door at the...
The door disappears and we didn't notice it.
We did not see it.
It was apparently...
Bottles.
Come back!
Look!
It was a missing book on down.
Oh no!
No!
Okay, that's fine.
It's back here.
Where's the doll?
Um.
Is outside?
Did we just...
Is it...
Did we just like softlock ourselves?
Where's the...
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I hear it, I hear it.
I found it.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait, is that...
Dude, the light bulbs here.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, okay.
All right.
Not all hope is lost.
Okay, apparently, apparently there was a door that we
missed.
Oh, that one?
It's like door at the end of the hallway?
Like, leave?
Leave?
This is the one right here?
Wait, leave.
And then let me see if anything changes.
Okay, okay.
Every woman says that.
I will know if my life changes when you leave.
Oh!
What?
Yeah, something changed.
What happened?
Something, um...
Oh, you could jump through the window.
Yeah, yeah, I could jump through the window.
You...
Hello!
I gotta shove my toy through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You gotta throw it.
You gotta throw the light, throw the flat, the light thingy.
Because you can't chuck it, we can't chuck it on the door.
You have to, we need the...
Oh, you mean the light bulb?
Yeah, we need the light bulb, but you have to...
Where did you drop it?
Right next to you.
I don't see it.
Oh, it's without the light, so yeah, throw the doll away.
Oh, okay, okay, like towards...
Throw the doll away, cause the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I think I see it.
Oh, frick, actually, I don't see it.
Oh, no, okay, wait, I come back.
Where did I drop it?
Wait, where did it go?
wait what the fuck where did it go i don't know wait okay
wait i got the bear where the bear where did it go wait it's
gone wait i'm i'm jumping off i'm jumping off do it i'm
gonna do it better i don't know where the it disappeared
like rolls on I think it rolled into the cliff.
Wow, we were...
Okay, okay, we figured it out.
We figured it out.
Wait, where's the...
Wait.
What happened to the...
What happened to the light?
You might have to get it again.
Wait, wait, unless...
Okay, I'm gonna move it around.
Do you see it anywhere?
No.
I think we gotta get...
Oh, no.
No, I don't see it.
You guys have got to go through this again, maybe?
All right, yeah.
It respawns?
Oh, no.
All right, here we go.
Poppies.
All right.
All right, here we go.
And then...
Oh, then you get a light bulb.
And you get a light bulb.
And we all get a light bulb.
There we go.
All right, let's do this.
We got to figure it out.
We're still good at this game.
Yeah, I know.
Teamwork.
See?
We're bonding.
All right.
Open the door.
Oh, I got help.
Yeah, you got to jump.
All right.
Let's go.
Okay, oops.
Don't break it.
That'll be pretty awkward.
All right, I should be fine.
Okay, don't get close.
Don't get close to the window.
I'll stay there.
Because I got to chuck that.
All right.
Alright, I chucked it.
Okay, I'm going.
You can't bring the bear over, remember?
The glass.
Oh, no.
But I love my bear.
Wait, is it?
Oh, wait.
Where's the power?
Oh, is it not there?
I don't remember where it is.
Well, Jack's set to bring it over there, so if they're
wrong...
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Okay, that's what I thought.
That's what I thought, Jack.
They're nice.
Yeah, I come over here, though.
Oh, I was playing with my bear.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say it.
I was like, I'll get over here.
Wait, if I put this here, how do we turn on that lever?
Oh, from this.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me push this over.
Then it's your turn to turn on that lever.
Ow.
Oh.
Watch your head.
Oh, I think something bad is coming out of there.
Don't worry.
Everything will be fine.
Oh, good.
Look at that.
We got soda.
Soda.
Free soda.
Alright, into that.
Oh.
Hey, that's where the feet went.
Remember that?
Oh!
Oh, it's not feet.
It's not feet.
It's not feet no more.
Oh, no.
He dabbed this up.
He dabbed.
He squashed his, like, little insects.
Maybe we should not have, like, looked at it.
But I know.
It doesn't like eye contact.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, I'm running.
I'm running.
I'm running straight for it.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Under here.
There's no way.
There's no way he can tell.
I don't think we're meant to do this.
It's okay.
There's no way.
See, he does know.
See, look at that.
Why is this, like, so well-animated?
I know.
Oh, my God.
It had, look at, like, the little pores, the little wrinkles
on his arms, too.
Oh.
Ew, don't fall.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Lick his fingers.
ah he said i like your cut g how did he know okay okay we
gotta wait we're until the okay now we go let's squish that
ears he doesn't have her ears he can't hear us vibration
okay don't worry be very very quiet go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go Oh my god, do a flip.
You did a flip.
Do a flip.
Okay, okay.
It's fine.
I got this.
He doesn't know.
See, he has no ears.
He has no ears.
But that mug though, I'm taking that with us.
Chibi, you gotta drop it so we can do a piece, Chibi.
Oh.
Oh, you're so lucky.
I'm establishing dominance.
Yeah.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
The right side.
the right side what are we supposed to crouch oh were we but
he heard it oh maybe i don't know he heard yeah i thought we
just run oh we crouched to the to the box and then he'll
like be like what was that yeah maybe i'm crouching okay i
think we're wrong i think we're wrong i think we're wrong i
think we're wrong i think we're I don't know.
We sprint out and crouch?
We try that, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Because there was a box there.
My chat is saying you have to be, like, frame perfect.
Actually, you do run.
So I think...
But my chat lies for fun all the time.
Why can't they get on?
Oh.
Okay, go, go, go, go.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're gaming.
We're gaming.
Okay.
Hammer back.
Hammer.
I'm hammered.
I got it.
Donkey smash.
Okay, there you go.
I'm just a pile of leaves.
Why don't you leave?
Oh!
He does have eyes.
It's like that Guillermo del Toro film, The Labyrinth.
The guy that eats fairies?
I love that movie!
Oh, that is such a good... Yeah, yeah, he's like that guy.
The guy who eats fairies.
That scene in that movie scared...
Like, actually it was the first movie I've ever seen that
made me scared.
That was a good-ass movie.
It's really good.
I need to be stuck on a plant.
with the plants all right wait what oh that was a walk oh oh
are we oh we're safe we're safe just out of them just a
little spores won't worry you know we're immune it's like a
power-up yeah yeah yeah it's pre last of us i've never
played that game it's pretty fun there's a lot of stealth
stuff though.
I think we go upstairs.
Yeah.
There's a staircase.
Maybe he's a mushroom man because there's so much mushrooms
around us.
Mushroom man.
Okay.
Oh, there's a key here.
All right.
Push.
Oh, soda.
Grab a Soda for the ride.
It's gonna be a long day.
Soda.
There's a putta.
Oh, here.
Oh, he can't see.
Oh!
Guys, guys, that's nice.
Oh, there's a nice.
Shoot the plant!
Shoot the plant, shoot the plant, shoot the plant!
Watch this.
360.
Oh, no, it's busy sucking.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It's busy sucking the life out of her.
Nice.
Oh, there's a...
There's the key.
I got it?
Let's go.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'll wait for you on the other side.
I'll come back for you.
I'm coming.
All right.
Open sesame.
Easy.
All right.
Oh.
Wait, turn on the lever, cronk.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where's the...
Almost got me.
Wait, is the teddy bear back here?
Oh, you think so?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Oh, I got it, I got it, got it, got it.
Don't worry.
Chucking it over.
Oh, never mind.
I have weak arm game.
I know someone who doesn't have a weak right arm right now.
Pick up your fucking teddy.
This is your teddy bear.
Pick it.
Pick up your toy.
I got it.
Oh, I got it.
Pick it up.
This is your toy.
I ain't cleaning your room.
Oh, my.
You're so lucky that you don't, it doesn't, you just drop to
the pit.
We just go for it.
Oh, where are you?
Did we come from this door?
Oh, there's, this is over.
Oh, oh, look.
This is nicer.
It's not so bad.
Oh, with the teddy bear light, it's nice.
Yeah.
See, that girl has a nice bed.
Being crazy is not too bad.
Oh, wait.
Wait, put the...
Take the bear out?
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, you can't bring the bear in.
Okay, should I wait?
The bear...
No, I think you come with me.
The bear stays within the crazy room.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
There's zombies, there's zombies, there's zombies.
We gotta sneak.
not zombies are not real
i thought i was gonna do that it's gonna yeah yeah it's it's
like 20 of them in the row you know the force of it it's
like i was trying to get play of the game it's like a little
skewer you're making a zombie skewer oh yeah kebab yeah yeah
yeah yeah they all lined up you know it was a perfect lineup
yeah i was using my mccreel chrycasity i don't know where to
go this is really creepy oh my god they're like mannequins
it's like one of the i don't remember which little
nightmares it was but it was like all mannequins second one
yeah yeah that shit fucking sucked i need to replay that
game it was so good
terrible that actually got me he was like yeah you want to
play that game again all right i think Maybe they don't like
the light.
Like little nightmares, too.
Oh.
Thread the needle.
Oh, they don't care.
They only care about sound.
Yeah.
Thread the needle, Cheeby.
This is what it's like at TwitchCon.
Thread the needle.
Oh, I don't...
But these are RL streamers.
Wait, actually.
Oh, that's true.
But I think it's up here, and then we go right.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
made it i'm so freaking scared don't worry just five more oh
oh there's more there's more there's more there's more
there's more don't run don't run don't start running okay
don't start running she's a runner she's a track stop wait
where do we go from here i think maybe in this oh it's oh
that's like a little oh my god oh my auto save auto save oh
thank god oh thank god when you jumped in they all turned to
me yeah my bad i hear some When we meet the long boy.
Long, long, man.
Oh, here, here.
Long, man.
Alright.
Oh, we're outside.
Oh, we're not outside.
The outside came to us.
Oh, wait.
No, we are.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
We are outside.
There's a shoe in there.
Our foot in there.
Nice.
Oh.
Do the jump.
I didn't watch too many rocks today.
Yeah, we didn't.
We shouldn't have been rocks.
We were synchronized.
That would have gotten like a perfect score in the Olympics.
I know, right?
Summer Olympics sign us up.
I guess we wait, right?
Yeah, maybe we just wait.
What do we do?
What?
Oh, I shoot something?
Oh, the light?
No.
Oh, no.
Oh, I got this.
What?
Oh, I didn't see that.
That wasn't here before.
You're fucking good.
I'll keep going.
Later, don't do that.
Your butt body blocked me.
Your fat ass.
I parried you.
Yeah, your ass parried back.
It, like, bounced back.
Yeah, I shook it a little and you went flying.
It's like Super Smash Bros.
I was edgeguarding.
Alright.
I have awaited your arrival.
For many a millennium.
I'm almost there.
Doki Bird.
Hello.
The prophecy as we're told.
No, I have a story I have to tell you.
What?
Did you know?
Okay.
I saw you on an iPad at a con once before we were friends.
Oh, shit.
So, seriously?
funny it was really funny because it was ira like were you
in there in real life oh okay okay okay the handlers coming
yeah wait what oh no it's okay it's oh that's the tv show
host i know him
Oh, I got you queen back up the lady.
Oh Oh, was that a QTE?
Yeah, I think that was a cute.
I think you're good.
I was like, I was deep in my butt crack.
I got you my queen.
Smash.
I thought that was a cutscene.
I was scratched my butt.
Oh, big.
Oh, no.
Wait, I think...
Anyways, this was like many, many years ago.
Mm-hmm.
We needed a different hair color.
And, um...
Yeah, before you got your hair.
Before I got it, it was a wig, you know.
It was a...
And I was looking at this one stall of art.
Yeah.
And this guy tapped me on the shoulder.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I gotta save you, Malini, one second.
Let me lock you.
Yeah, I gotta take the shot this time.
Okay.
Malini!
Ah!
That's right.
My hero.
Put the ball away.
the war just in case so this guy is really he's actually
very friendly tap me on the shoulder he's like hi excuse me
we're trying to look at the merch i was like oh i'm so sorry
and i noticed he was holding an ipad with a vtuber on it in
person i saw you and i waved to you it's like oh hi i was
like yeah sorry about that i'll move out the way and i was
like this is really cool that you like carry her around and
stuff like that and like i was like this is is this what
like eating is like you just carry your life food and uh and
i remember i told my one of my mods his name is gurg and i
described what you you looked like and he was like oh my god
oh my god you just met that dude i was like i had no idea
like who no no no i i didn't realize like how like like um i
guess like i i recognized who you were but i didn't know my
mods loved you that much and i I should have shouted you
out.
You'd be like, oh, that's me.
It's me.
But no, like, you guys were so friendly.
And that's so funny how when I were friends.
I like, it's so crazy.
Oh my, what a coincidence.
I know.
I mean, I guess it's kind of stretching it because you are
my dad.
Yeah, I'm your dad.
I have to be your friend.
You know, it's court- You know, it's court-ordered, you
know?
Yeah.
If I don't visit, daddy's got to go to jail.
Sarah would love her on the other side.
sands moods in here oh sweet hold up let me beat it up come
here yeah yeah beat up that kid i bet his dad there's a
bunch of nudes of sands but all right why don't you figure
that up and get water hi i'll be right back i think i missed
something now that i have you guys here alone what's your
favorite pokemon and i'm gonna tell you if it's a good pick
or not if it's evy sylveon or pikachu or snorlax you will be
beaten to death with hammers so please pick one Darkrai?
I will accept that.
He's kind of hot.
So I will...
Oh, you...
Okay, Doki needs to come in here.
There's a hole she can break.
Syndiquil?
I will accept that.
Typhlosion is pretty cool.
Lucario?
I know what the frick you are.
I know what you are.
My wild?
That's a good choice.
Peach, I will allow that.
Did you figure it out?
Yeah, you gotta come in here.
There's a wall you can break.
Okay, well...
Well, I think you have to pull the lever and then I break
the wall.
Yes.
All right, let me go back.
What's your favorite Pokemon?
What's my Sylveon?
What the frick did I just say, chat?
What?
I said.
Don't worry about it.
What?
That's a really good pick, Doki.
It is.
Sylveon's great.
Look, just like her.
That's why I hang out with you.
you okay sorry i'm just like that's why i made you look just
like her you know my favorite pokemon is um manafee and i
like ralts oh do you like ralts because of the final
evolution or because no no listen if i was gonna do a
pokemon it would be a different one wait which one would it
be dark eye or like maybe a geared dark eye wait why dark
wait i got a list i'll put it up okay well where's the wall
to the to the like left yeah i see i see i see it i see it
wait is dark guy because of pokemon mystery dungeon maybe i
freaking that's uh explorers is my favorite pokemon game so
good all right let's see all right what's the list new it's
up there oh i see him all right so what's the list what
which which is s tier probably dark eye and gyrtina why wait
why gyrtina if you don't get it you just don't get it but
like i'm sorry but honestly you want to know what's better
than every pokemon what bowser i feel like you're you're
also based and you can see the vision he's a good dad he's
loyal clearly because he only kidnaps yeah yeah he has eyes
for one person so he'll never
and obviously he's uh he's a very uh he you know he's loaded
too you know he has a castle he's literally the king is that
why you're no no he's like no i made no i meant okay all
right you're rich guys hit up her business email i meant
he's secure he's secure you know so like you don't have to
worry about like you know you know you don't have to worry
about you could be uh you could just you can you don't have
to worry about financial security because you already have
Financial security that is the best way to put being a gold
digger ever My mom always told me you can always fall in
love with a man's wallet It makes sense that you also have a
similar feeling.
Oh, no, I don't I don't need no man's wallet.
I have my own wallet Hey, yo, then why don't you ever buy me
food?
Yeah, it says my wallet Why don't you you that you didn't
earn it chibi you freaking alone But you grab the key right?
Yeah.
All right.
I think it's back here then.
Oh yeah, it's back here.
Boop.
Oh, I found the lock.
Okay.
What's over here though?
I have a wallet, but it's like from like when I was in high
school.
So it's like, uh, falling apart and it looks like the inside
of a couch cushion.
It's really bad.
Oh no.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Um.
keep the money in it oh yeah yeah yeah you can have it it's
literally just my pocket i just put my money in my pocket i
feel like you're the kind of girl who only rolls in 100s no
i actually don't carry cash anymore me either i just tell
people don't rob me yeah i don't carry cash no more all
right let's what the why are we here why did we unlock why
are we in this box yeah
button button button oh button it's a light switch okay but
there's still nothing oh he's a conspiracy theorist look at
him that's just a theory a game theory maybe on the other
side
oh because like there was a second floor remember like up
top yeah yeah we have to go from here it to go to the other
side you're gonna be on in this we're gonna be in your
ceiling oh never mind by the way you cannot judge me on my
hear me out so don't you want to like go in the exhaust pipe
of an airplane no i want to watch it happen no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no because
it's there's variables to it it depends on who it is you
know okay so like when there's two males go
I'm reformed I'm reformed I'm reformed I'm reformed I don't
really like Yahweh like or Yuri but like depends on a couple
you know yeah yeah see it depends on who it is you know like
I'm like if they love each other I'm like oh get it get it
yeah yeah yeah I cannot believe you're a Yahweh fan no no
I'm reformed I'm ex I'm an ex Yahweh fan I'm a ex Ujo are
you in the Yuri now did you did you upgrade i'm into i'm i'm
into elo i'm elo yeah i'm into i don't want to hold your
hand while we're talking about i'm into rank points you know
i mean there ain't no time every time you wake up you're you
start spamming right click
this better not be the end of the game because we're not
ending on a conversation like this i i there's no way oh
yeah i was gonna say it the cat just end we're like we found
a door and we hands so go back to the yaoi airplane stuff
you want to like uh watch so you know like you know like the
the uh you know when star scream well star scream was like
the bicycle hey you like this guy he's got big hands that's
a yaoi right not not my yaoi not you like it not my yaoi
Yeah, where's the other guy?
He's at the end of this tunnel.
He's at the end.
Watch out.
You're about to be the other guy.
But left or right.
Be careful.
Jump!
Take the jump!
Oh my god.
He's coming to lick you.
We have to go this way!
Who wants to put you in the... He wants to war you right
now.
I feel like you would also be a girl who's in the war.
Noバイ- Нет!
If it's two men, are you in divorced?
What do you think about it?
N-no, no, no, no, not- no for- no for Have you ever seen-
How you ever seen, like...
Oh, wait.
See what?
Hit the gong.
I'm going over, I'm going over, I'm going over with the
hammer.
I'm thinking about Yaoi, I'm thinking about Yaoi.
Bam?
Which one?
Which one are you thinking of?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
I did.
I died doing what I love.
Hitting that gun.
Look, I got curious.
You were...
I wanted to know which one you were thinking about.
I've actually never read Yallin.
Oh my god.
Oh my... Okay.
Hitting the gun.
Have you read?
Wait, so did you read it or like watch it?
Read.
I let my imagination take me.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
It's okay.
He's too thick for it.
His hands.
He's too thick.
You gotta go on a diet.
You gotta get on that ozempic.
He's gonna lose his vision, though.
Oh, that's true.
Are you ready for this?
He's gonna get a... Oh, yeah, touch it.
Alright.
Love Yahweh.
Let me... Oh.
Whoa.
Every boy.
This is another boy.
Well, you get to watch Doki Bird in this dimension.
You get to watch.
Are you ready?
Maybe I...
Welcome to the world of Gasek.
Maybe I'm gonna...
Maybe...
Maybe not today.
Wait a second.
Wait...
It's fine.
Okay, come on.
We've got a waiting for you.
They want you to watch.
Okay, maybe...
They're putting on chapstick right now.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm reformed.
I've grown as a person.
It's not me anymore.
It's not my...
That's not me anymore.
It's a CEO with a new hire and he's got really big pectorals
and his nipples poke through the shirt.
And one is like five foot two and the other seven foot
eight.
I'll go in and we can watch together.
Oh, no, I took it back.
No, I took it back.
We can watch it together.
It's like co-op cooking.
It's a bench.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Instead of a chair.
It's all.
Oh, no.
This guy's homophobic.
She said, no, it's got to be between a man and a woman.
It's Adam and Eve, not Adam and Steve.
Yes, it's way too, Bo.
Oh, Fred, where do we go?
Where do we go?
Oh, oh, it's TV.
Oh, what?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, this way.
Wait, the gong.
The gong.
This open.
Okay.
I freaking love the gong.
Oh, wait.
I'm tripping.
I'm tripping out.
She's thinking about the gong.
I got so nervous, I started tripping.
Summon the boy kissers.
Oh, wait, it's up to you.
You, you, you, you, you, you, you, arrow, arrow, arrow,
arrow, arrow.
Oh, oh, hey, oh, hey, oh, hey, oh, hey, hey, hey.
Could I get him?
I think so.
Oh, yeah, his hand died.
He can't, he can't jork it with that one now.
Wait, where am I?
Soda?
Where am I?
I can't see myself.
It's so dark.
Your glasses are fogging up after thinking about what we
were talking about.
just like where am i where am i dude this is actually really
cool yeah this is a cool boss but yeah oh there is go home
wait wait wait how do we okay get down there you go all
right i'll think about y'all way down here you think about
it up here i'm trying oh my god oh my god please please
please please please please please all right shoot him shoot
oh please oh please oh please oh no okay I like lag switch
there.
You perfect framed that.
It's fine.
We know now.
We know.
Wait, where does that go?
The gong goes over there.
Okay, but like we're due all these fall though.
Alright.
Okay, the gong falls down here.
Yeah, there you go.
Come, come, come.
Okay, okay.
Do you believe in yourself?
I believe in the power of Yahweh.
You said you were right back then.
Back then.
No, no, no.
I meant like past jerky.
Past jerky.
I'm talking about the past.
Now I don't believe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm reformed.
I got no time for that no more.
I think you weren't late today because you were sleeping.
I think you were reading Alwyn.
No, I was...
You weren't late, but you know, you like woke up five
minutes before.
Okay.
Gone time.
Are you talking to me past Doki?
Do you mean like 10 seconds ago?
Gone time.
Shoot the eye.
Heal.
There we go.
Look at that.
We're so good at this game.
We're such a good team.
Father.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, do we shoot it?
Do we?
Oh, you got to hammer him.
Pretend you're a guy.
Hammer time.
Wait, he still has his eyes.
Wait, you gotta shoot the eyes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Yeah.
That's right.
But now you're blind forever.
Oh, okay, don't worry.
Do not pull a little nightmares too, okay?
Don't worry.
Do not.
I'm gripping you.
Oh, no.
My hands are so slippery.
Oh no!
No!
Oh, it was just... It was just a little nightmare.
Three!
My thought was so sad!
Guys, if you hear voices, don't take medicine.
This is what happens.
You're real.
Yeah, you lose your best friend.
Wait, maybe we're just in the garbage.
Oh, no, I just...
Oh, I am the Yahweh artist.
You're drawing these scenes out.
You're writing fan fiction right now.
You're writing...
You're making a dojin or a fan fiction.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, see, I told you...
I told you not to take your meds.
Look at that.
Every time you don't take your meds, I appear.
Wait, that hair is so cute.
That is cute, yeah.
Oh, we're taking commissions.
Alright.
You gotta pay triple if you want...
not safe for work stuff.
No, you'll probably charge less because you want to draw
that stuff.
No, no, no.
Do you know, like, furry porn is a very lucrative business?
Oh, yes.
Did you know, like, most doctors are, like, furries?
Oh, and politicians, too.
Yeah, and v-tubers.
And, and, like, and, like, uh, engineers.
Yeah, and, like, scientists.
They could, they could, they live among us.
The game should have ended two cutscenes ago.
I'm full of piss.
and it's about to make it every oh my god you are the crazy
one look you are the crazy this is me you are the crazy one
i knew it i knew i wasn't real i was never real you you
walked off the cliff didn't you you walked on that i'm
dressed with my beautiful hair uh oh oh oh no no i don't
have my hair no more
Oh, on my end, I'm back to my, to my beautiful mask.
Do not touch the hands.
The feet is in front of us.
We won't touch that.
Oh my gosh.
I want to go between his toes.
Oh, you got to climb it.
Oh, wait, you got to touch the mirror.
I don't have my bow anymore.
I don't have my, I have my hammer with me.
Alright.
If you touch that mirror.
If you're reformed.
No, if you touch that mirror, I'll be real.
But you got to come in.
Come there with me.
To the world.
Of heterosexual love.
That's what I thought.
I know what you want.
No, no, no, no.
See, I'm here.
I'm here.
Just kidding.
You got baited.
Oh, what?
You don't know what?
Oh, because I'm not real.
Oh, because you're reformed.
Yeah, I'm reformed.
See, I told you.
I was like, don't bring me back.
Don't bring me.
Wait, why did it kick me out?
You don't have a pure heart.
I have a pure heart.
I've read things.
My heart is too pure.
They saw my past.
I'll say you did a costume change.
You win it.
as your guy and came oh you're naked yeah yeah i was like
i'm not pure yeah you remember i'm butt naked what are you
doing it's like what's the point of following social norms
oh i can't wait to launch a theory explanation video in this
game because i was too busy laughing this entire time
That was like the entry into heaven and God like pulled up
your search history.
It was like boys kissing, boys touching, boy love.
They're like, we know what you, we know what you were.
Guys were because I am reformed now.
I'm different.
It's different now.
That was actually really good.
I like the ending.
They're like, you can't run from your past.
We know what you are.
It's okay.
I got caught watching Yuri when I was a kid by my mom.
Yeah.
What Yuri was it?
Okay, so I went on YouTube and as everyone does, I Googled
who's kissing.
And a couple- I got a dog!
Really?
This Yowie Cuck airplane infiltrator.
Who's everyone?
You want to stick your fist in the exhaust pipe of an
airplane and then get back and watch it get gone.
I said, I want to watch.
I want to watch.
What do you want to watch him do?
I want to watch it happen.
I'm just a casual bystander.
It's where research possible.
No, it's research, you know.
I'm just researching car anatomy.
Oh, so now it's cars and airplanes.
Yeah, yeah, no.
Yeah, I'm researching airplane and car anatomy, you know?
Like I want to, what if I have to repair an airplane or
repair a car in the future?
You know, I got to be a resource.
you know whatever to have to change a tire at an airport
don't ever work at an airport what about to change a tire i
got a research you know i got you're gonna get too excited
but i i was one i googled girls kissing yeah and the first
one of the first or like anime girl kissing girl whatever
because i'm you know whatever i was 12 years old and i just
moved to the states and i just got on the internet access
and i i googled that and i clicked the first link and it was
like from this like school girl anime i don't even remember
what it was but they were like yeah yeah that stuff under a
tree and like in a school yeah and uh i like watched it and
like i was trying like i didn't know like what like that
kind of stuff was but i was like i really like that i don't
know why i'm gonna i'm gonna suppress that for 20 years and
then and then my little my little sister that freaking rat
saw it in the shared youtube history on the youtube account
and showed my mom so she's like that's me mom she's a rat
damn snitches get stitches you know what they say done for
him.
I'm not paying for a college anymore.
Wait, is there after credit scene for this, guys?
I'll speed it up.
Yeah, I've been speeding up the entire time.
Carrie.
I don't even know if there's like...
I don't know if there's loops.
Shout out to Pete.
I'm at sales now.
Oh, there's after credits.
There's an after credit.
Does this loop, guys?
Does the credits...
Yeah, because I've had that happen where I kept scrolling,
and then like, I was like, I feel like I've seen this guy's
name like three times.
And in my chat, I was like, you've been looping for like 10
minutes now.
And I was like, this is a very long credit.
Yeah, it's like, this is a very long credit sequence.
Oh my god, do you think it's after credits?
Yeah, wait.
Is that why you want to get through it?
Oh, it doesn't loop.
It doesn't loop guys.
It doesn't.
Wait, does this loop actually?
Wait, no, no, it doesn't.
I'm at Eastern Europe right now.
All right, here's the commercial director, Franz Ferdinand,
Christoph.
I'm engineering.
Bandai, Southern Europe, Alberto, Gonzales, Lorca.
I'm at Italy now.
What the frick is a PIM specialist?
PIM from Smiling.
Oh.
Production in management.
Tag yourself.
I'm...
I'm Breckery.
Auntie.
I am Manisha.
I think it's looping.
It's not looping.
I'm at testers now.
And it's just a lot of names.
There's Ritu George.
There's like, how many shivas is there?
Okay, that's two.
Two shivas.
I'm at Suria.
I'm at Dishno Quality Assurance Testing.
There's Matthew.
Can you read out every name for me?
Joel Foot, Jonathan Yeats, Jordan, Jordan, Jordan, Curtis,
Kyle, Lewis, Matthew, Richard, Robin, Sophie, Will, Lombra,
Michael I got you parisocial fans maybe she said your name
there clip it tag yourself if I said your name guys talk to
yourself right now she's talking to you it's real Julia uh
Carla Yuri oh hey Yuri wait so I'm the Yuri one together
together we make a straight couple
We did it.
We did full circle.
See, it's not gay.
It's not gay.
One is for Yowie and the other is for Yuri.
It's 100% straight.
We're thinking of both genders.
So it's like...
It's technically heterosexual.
Okay, but apparently we're from Alabama.
All right.
Digital marketing.
Oh my god.
I felt like I've seen marketing.
20 times it's not looping hey hey hey genius hit escape we
can skip it hit hit it hit back oh i'm waiting for you stop
thinking about boys there you go are we gonna click that
whole time and i didn't and not and not recognize the the
people that were worked so hard in this game wow chibi you
don't want to give credit to people who made this wonderful
game draw hers an airplane
I did this once as a kid and I cut myself I thought I
thought it was a rock I got excited guys like look a shiny
rock yeah don't worry show you he can glue it back it's like
it's like monsters ink when they shredded a door he'll just
yeah glue it back oh
I really like this game yeah that's nice I wonder what the
like the the hidden like laura behind everything is like the
the the game theories yeah oh i've lost connection to the
other player we did it we finally completed it i close that
game so freaking quick yeah you were yeah i was like and
you're thinking of other things because you're thinking
about y'all we need to i i'm so proud of us chibi that we
have this this the collab was cursed since the beginning
with i feel like every time we try to stream this game like
one of us would get sick like yeah or like oh sorry i
severed my arm off yeah everything came in between yeah yeah
but we did it we did it chibi we made it through and we had
another game yeah we should honestly yeah i mean there's
wait have you played re-animal yet what is it called
re-animal Okay, re-animal is um is from the creators of
little nightmares.
They made it.
Yeah.
It's like a spiritual.
Yeah, we could do that next.
Yeah, I'll see you in four months.
Oh, thanks.
But we did.
I can't believe it, Chibi.
Oh, shit.
It's getting bigger.
The stuff.
Yeah.
It's about to come out.
It's like a pimple, you know?
You can like yeah you squeeze the pimple out like the just
pop it out pop it pop it twist it I can't but I'm so proud
of us chibi I can't do it the game together we work yeah we
work together people doubted us you know they all doubted us
they thought they're like these all thought we wouldn't get
it done but we showed them we showed them they were like so
much fun my stomach hurts from laughing I think my Oh my god
And I won Chicken Edging He technically did win You
technically Cause you didn't die Yeah I did No Also cause
like I was the one That got trapped You know He didn't got
me Yeah Cause he took me Cause I Yeah yeah I will respect it
Yeah you were too chicken I'm more chicken It's alright It's
alright But I'm proud of us It was so fun Cheevy Yeah there
was a lot of fun Yeah, yeah, I had a good time.
Oh my gosh.
Did you eat dinner yet?
I heard you like Yowie.
Wait, why do you have that toggle as someone that is?
Why do you have that toggle, TV?
Because my viewers wish I was a guy, so I put that on
sometimes when I'm desperate.
Oh, and just to give them something.
Just to, like, give them something.
You know?
So you're Yowie, basically.
You're gay baiting essentially.
I wish it was a bait It's not it's not bait.
It's real.
I wish you like that that like that picture the wolf would
pick its shirt off I like I try it just I can't get it off
You know you know that meme yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah It's like
fused it onto your body at that point Yeah, that you can
never run you can never escape who you are Who you truly are
that's so deep.
That's so deep Mm-hmm.
All right, I hope you feel better.
I know you were sick, so I'm glad you got the flavor.
Yeah, yeah, I hope you get better too.
I was, because like at first, Jibu was like, I think I can
only do two hours, Jokia.
I was like, oh, that's cool.
I was like, we'll push through it.
Yeah, I would be like, you were like, I don't know when
she'll come back.
Like, when's the next visitation day?
I can look this.
I did.
She's like, I don't know when dad will come back from his
next trip.
Like, I know.
i had to get my happiness while it was here yeah she had to
like make sure she took advantage of all the time i could
provide for today before before we ran out of milk again
which by the way she beyond unfortunately um during the
entire playthrough um i think we both drank the entire kind
of milk i brought for today and i know you you're a growing
girl you know like you know we're still not really it's not
you know you're you're just a late bloomer chibi you know
the milk will eventually work so i gotta grab some more milk
so you continue to grow and eventually it's gonna work chibi
i i believe um mom and i both believe that one day like the
the puberty is gonna hit but anyway i gotta go i gotta don't
worry i'll be back i don't worry there's there's there's
like of Cheetos in the fridge so don't worry yeah yeah
there's a bag of Cheetos in the fridge I'll I'll be back so
it'll last longer you know I don't know how I'll yeah it'll
last longer that should last you a couple of days maybe
weeks you know I'll I'll it's okay I'm like playing survivor
like single player yeah you can you can craft yeah just
remember how to craft Yeah.
Okay, I have one final message before I go.
Well, that was fun, guys.
I was surprised that we actually finished the game today
because our initial plan was to like play two hours because
she said like, you know, for those who didn't see her on
Twitter, see on Twitter, she was having throat issues today.
so um i am i plotting her to power through that uh
especially with all the yelling so i hope she i hope her
throat recovers too but yeah i'm glad we finished we finally
finished little nightmares three after four months i told
you guys it was just a very very um it was just a very very
very long traffic jam i i would have got back home sooner uh
i swear guys I would have been back sooner if only there was
a lot of you know there was deer crossing there was like
goose cross geese crossing there was like there was a
traffic there was a car crash like there was some final
destination shit going on so we had to wait there and
everything you know and then I needed it to I need a smoke
break I get to like pit stops you know it was sort of like a
mini road trip with all the little road side like road road
attractions there i take picture of the large the largest
rubber band ball and everything no i i don't smoke but i
like lighting the cigarette and then like um and then and
you know for the vibes you know for the aura uh
I'm gonna call it here.
There will still be a member stream later today, but it
might be like in two hours, two to three hours because I
haven't had dinner yet, guys.
So I'm gonna, I'm gonna, actually, yeah, I'll be in two to
three hours because I'm gonna grab dinner and then, or we
can do it on Sunday for the member goons.
You guys wanna, do you wanna do the, Do you want to do a
member stream on Sunday, guys?
I'll do a member stream and bonus member stream.
I'll make the waiting room.
I'll do a bonus member stream at around 5 p.m.
Yeah, I'll do that then for you guys because I know some of
you guys want to sleep.
I saw you like, please, Doki, free us.
Free us, Doki.
be mpsd i will i'll do a member stream for you guys um and
we'll just hang out we'll hang out together um it's just
gonna be a chill relaxing one anyways i'm i'm actually a bit
eepy like i said i like i didn't get a lot i didn't get good
i didn't get good sleep today um i've been oh she she she's
gone she disappeared it's okay she's at the she's in the
fridge eating her cheetos right now um i was gonna say but i
had really bad sleep today because i was coughing a lot um
but uh maybe maybe tomorrow would be better maybe tomorrow
would be better hey guys thank you all for coming thank you
all for watching as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around get that blood flowing and you
stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you
guys next time everybody bye guys bye